bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaires si vous nous
rejoignez pour cette grande soirée
électorale premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle on vous propose deux
débats politiques et un débat d'experts
dans les heures qui viennent mais
d'abord les toutes dernières estimations
de ce premier tour de l'élection fournis
par nos partenaires ipsos sopra steria
réussi les deux finalistes les deux
qualifiés pour le second tour de cette
élection 2022 emmanuel macron arrive en
tête avec 28 4 % des suffrages c'est une
estimation évidemment marine le pen à 23
4 ap
jean luc mélenchon troisième position
21,1 pour cent eric zemmour 7% valérie
pécresse finissent sous les 5% à 4,7
pour cent
yannick jadot le candidat europe
ecologie les verts à 4,5 pour cent
ensuite on trouve jean lassalle 3,2
fabien roussel le candidat communiste à
2,4 nicolas dupont aignan 2,1 pour cent
à nidal go 1,8 pour cent pour la
candidate du parti socialiste
ensuite c'est philippe plutôt à 0,8 et
nathalie arthaud à
0,6 pour semble tout au long de cette
soirée vous entendrez bien évidemment ou
réentendre et toutes les déclarations
des candidats et des candidats ils se
sont tous exprimés sauf un emmanuel
macron nous attendons évidemment la
déclaration du candidat qui est arrivé
en tête ce soir et vous la vivre et on
dirait que tu alcp et et public sénat on
vous fait vivre également cette soirée
avec nos envoyés spéciaux dans les qg on
est au parc des expositions de la porte
de versailles avec les soutiens des
manuels macron justement et c'est elsa
monde un gamin qui nous représente sur
place si j'ose dire au parc floral dans
le 12e arrondissement avec marine le pen
c'est à mme tran huy au cirque d'hiver
avec jean luc mélenchon fait un peu trop
vite on retrouve stéphanie des pierres
et puis nous sommes aussi à la maison de
la mutualité aux côtés d'eric zemmour
des ses équipes avec marie brémaud et
puis nous avons aperçu tam tran huy il
ya quelques instants qui était au parc
floral à côté des soutiens de marine le
pen
alors un filet sur l'un des dix plaies
que je pense que les positions sont
prêtes oui évidemment on peut retrouver
et les amendes à gaza qui est au qg des
mânes et le maquereau on attend toujours
la déclaration du président sortant
oui on l'avait annoncé un peu après 21h
ici les militants sont chauffés à blanc
puisque la soirée électorale de france 2
est diffusé on a donc suivi le convoi du
président candidat il devrait donc
prendre la parole dans quelques instants
beaucoup de soulagement ici au parc des
expositions emmanuel macron et premier
bien devant marine le pen mais on le
sait aussi pas de triomphalisme il faut
faire campagne dans l'entre-deux tours
on annonce déjà un déplacement du
candidat président dans le nord terre du
rassemblement national il faut
convaincre de voter pour emmanuel macron
et pas simplement contre marine le pen
c'est un des mots d'ordre de cette
équipe de campagne
merci l amont d'un gars va et on part à
présent dans le qg de l'autre finaliste
qui est marine le pen ce soir nous
sommes en parc floral dans le 12e
arrondissement de la capitale tam vous
êtes sur place marine le pen qui réalise
un score plus élevé qu'en 2017
et oui effectivement un brigitte environ
deux points de plus un peu plus de deux
points de plus qu'en 2017 et du coup ici
les élus les militants ils croient ils
croient en la victoire à l'image de
marine le pen qui lorsqu'elle s'est
exprimé peu après 20h30 avec tout un
vocabulaire autour de l'optimisme à la
parler le gratitude d'espoir et adressé
un message de rassemblement elle a dit
qu'elle était libre des attaches
partisanes au service de tous présidente
de tous les français
et elle a adressé un message aux
français de droite de gauche d'ailleurs
et on a senti notamment cet appel du
pied aux électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
qui a atteint les 20% lorsqu'elle a
parlé notamment justice sociale ou
encore égalité femmes hommes on comprend
marine le pen me sur l'exaspération à
l'égard d' emmanuel macron elle espère
le ralliement du plus grand nombre vous
l'avez dit elle et deux points au dessus
de 2010 est la stratégie va être encore
affiner un demain matin en bureau
national et à 14h30 lors d'un bn élargi
en tout cas eh bien ils espèrent encore
mener une campagne de terrain avec déjà
deux meetings qui sont prévus dans
l'entre-deux tours
merci thème très nuit pour toutes ces
informations vous avez entendu tous nos
experts en première partie de soirée
nous poursuivons évidemment cette soirée
sur lcp sur public sénat avec notre
premier plateau politique et nous
accueillons à présent laurent saint
martin bonjour bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes député la république en marche du
val de marne et puis emmanuel blé riz en
face de vous bonsoir vous êtes député
rassemblement national du pas-de-calais
eric coquerel bonsoir des bouchons et la
france insoumise de seine-saint-denis et
charles continue bonsoir bonsoir avocats
responsables société civile de la
campagne de valérie pécresse
laurent saint martin je rappelle l'autre
dernière estimation ipsos au prince
derrière vous êtes emmanuel macron à 28
4%
5 points devant marine le pen qui est à
23 points 4 c'est un élan un bon élan
oui d'abord les français se sont
déplacés dans les urnes contrairement à
ce qu'on nous faisait craindre ces
derniers jours et ces dernières semaines
c'est une première bonne nouvelle la
deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est
effectivement que le bilan du président
de la république et de la majorité est
saluée et que nombre de français
souhaite effectivement cinq ans de plus
pour emmanuel macron pour beaucoup de
raisons qu'on évoquera probablement tout
à l'heure ensuite ne me demandez pas à
titre personnel de me réjouir à partir
du moment où l'extrême droite est au
second tour dans notre pays c'est
toujours un échec c'est toujours
dangereux que c'est un échec des manuels
maquereau ou c'est un échec pour la
république que l'extrême droite soit en
capacité à gagner potentiellement
l'élection présidentielle donc c'était
absolument faire ce soir nous d'ordre il
est simple c'est tout les valeurs
républicaines doivent se rassembler pour
que manuel macron reste président de la
république ça quand plus pour que jamais
jamais notre pays puisse composer avec
l'extrême droite pour que jamais marine
le pen ne puisse utiliser des
institutions à des fins de division à
des fins de haine à des fins de peur et
surtout que nous puissions avoir une
présidente de la république pro poutine
dans un contexte international que vous
connaissez que je ne vous écris pas
quand le président actuel emmanuel
macron à lui fait preuve d'un leadership
européen que je crois beaucoup de
français ça du ce soir alors marine le
pen elle est très hot ce soit 23,1 6 %
contre 21 d'halo 3 % en 2017 pour vous
c'est une une première victoire déjà je
voudrais m'adresser mon collègue en face
qu'est ce que l'extrême droite c'est une
question importante puisque j'ai entendu
au moindre fois ce soir dans un premier
temps saluons quand même le déplacement
des français aux urnes c'est vrai sont
déplacés plus que prévu
ce soir nous appelons à rassembler tous
les français de droite de gauche et
notamment les abstentionnistes
les patriotes vous êtes tourné d'eric
coquerel en dix ans il a effectivement
aussi bien les électeurs
par là moi ne s'est pas abstenu nous on
a noté des
jeux le le corps parle c'est intéressant
voudra s'adresser aussi aux électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon s qui ressortait du
discours de marine le pen oui et moi qui
viens de une famille de gauche bien
ancrée dans le pas de calais j'ai à
coeur et au corps ou défendre la france
c'était la nation et on s'adresse
effectivement à l'ensemble des français
français qui sont à gauche qui défende
nos acquis sociaux face à la boutique de
macron et les français de droite qui
s'intéressent à nous à nos valeurs à
notre civilisation en matière aussi
d'immigration donc on s'adresse à tous
les français marine le pen est là pour
rassembler tous les français face à la
politique catastrophique qu'a mené
manuel macron pendant cinq années
maintenant il ya un bilan et un bilan ce
bilan est catastrophique on le dit on
est plusieurs crises on a croisé
traversée par des crises des crises
importantes que ce soit les gilets
jaunes
que ce soit dernièrement on a découvert
ce cabinet mckinsey qui a dirigé la
france pendant cinq ans marine le pen
diriger la france avec ses
fonctionnaires ses hauts fonctionnaires
dans le cas d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale voilà donc qu'on appelle un
semblant de tous les français seraient
évidemment l'occasion de répondre
notamment sur la question du cabinet
mckinsey je veux pas répondre sur
camille des maquis
c'était l'un des thèmes de la compagnie
vous avez aussi d'en faire trop sur les
mii qu'on a vu ce soir à quel point ça a
marché
marine le pen président de la république
ce qui compte ce soir c'est que les
français doivent savoir que c'est la
ruine économique c'est mettre à plat
tout ce qui a été fait pendant cinq ans
en termes de baisse du chômage et c'est
surtout composer avec l'ensemble des
politiques qui sont similaires c'est le
monsieur poutine
mais aussi celle de l'hongrie je crois
que vous ne le niez même pas vous
affichez avec le président hongrois et
je crois que ça les français doivent
d'abord le savoir c'est quoi l'extrême
droite puisque vous posiez la question
c'est quoi à l'extrême droite c'est
d'abord une force politique de haine de
division d'exclusion sont à 6 mars et
nous faut c'est totalement et c'est pas
une question que ça marche ou ça marque
par doha il est entendu ce droit
rappelle hans personnel noté monsieur je
suis engagé en 2002 contre l'extrême
droite et c'est le début de mon
engagement politique dès ce soir je suis
désolé ce soir je ne laisserai pas dire
la décentralisation nous aimons des
risques que vous représentez je me
réjouis sur la carte mais ces halles je
me réjouis chacun social c'est que ce
soit l'ensemble des formations
républicaine de cp un débat on a calé à
vos
marques et donc vous avez eu l'un et
l'autre largement la parole et vous
aurez l'occasion
j'imagine encore de vous opposer eric
coquerel qu'elle moi j'ai été surpris je
lave ou par l'image qu'a choisi jean luc
mélenchon dans son discours du rocher de
sisyphe le rocher de sisyphe il retombe
à chaque fois donc oui ça lorsque la
gauche perdra toujours dans un registre
show qu'il arrive si vous regardez ce
que nous incarnons comme gauche bien à
gauche de rupture un qui rompt avec le
néolibéralisme qui rompt avec sa 5ème
république pour le coup quand à deux
reprises on est très largement en tête
par rapport à toutes les autres forces
de gauche
là on a consolidé notre résultat on est
encore plus on rate le 2e tour d'un
cheveu je pense qu'on est du coup on est
moins redescendu qu'on l'était à mon
avis on va pouvoir augmenter beaucoup
plus vite moi ce soir je vois très
franchement on est déçu pas être au 2e
tour vous la faire votre vie avait cru
oui moi j'ai un moment la journée vous
dans son discours jean doyon qu'au fur
et à mesure et les résultats arrivent et
ce voyage chez certains médias je pense
qu'on est là à voir 21% vu ce qui était
en train de se passer
c'est passé à la réunion et aux tournées
majorité absolue je pense que ça va être
pareil pendant ma circonscription très
populaire de seine saint denis donc ce
qu'on voyait venir dans la jeunesse vous
voyez qu'on était beaucoup plus haut que
le disait un sondage est que les gens en
tout cas dans les gens qui ont intérêt à
voter pour un projet allait beaucoup
plus voter que le disais les sondeurs
donc je suis pas étonné après ce qui
nous a manqué c'est quoi c'est
l'effondrement de certains candidats
d'autres candidats de gauche qui se sont
malgré tout maintenu on va pas refaire
l'histoire on aura de très peu moi j'en
suis déçu pour notre pas parce que je
pense qu'on allait gagner l'élection
très sincèrement bon maintenant c'est
fait à partir de là nous on va
construire la suite et la suite c'est il
ya trois poules dans ce pays et un pôle
néolibérale il ya paul d'extrême droite
quoi qu'on en dise il ya un pool
populaire que nous incarnons sur des
valeurs que la gauche aurait jamais dû
quitter bons qui sont ceux de la
souveraineté populaire ceux du partage
des richesses partage du temps de
travail 6ème république et je crois que
à court terme eh ben c'est à nous de
justement consolider sa en tout cas si
l'appel que ce soir blouson autour de ce
que nous portons pour la suite voilà
après pour le deuxième tour on l'a dit
on pense qu'il ya bien une extrême
droite dans ce pays donc pas une voix
pour l'extrême droite maintenant j'avais
dit en appelant à voter non et manuelle
malot grands noms parce que monsieur une
forme d'ambiguïté il n'y a pas de aucune
ambiguïté d'accord j'ai donné on n'y a
pas vous avez vu jean luc mélenchon a
répété quatre fois d'époque n'est pas un
bilan de monsieur macro depuis
maintenant cinq ans accor ce bilan c il
s'en est pris aux libertés ils sont dix
prix à
l'égalité sociale il a développé le
quinquennat le plus inégal dans la vème
république donc c'est à lui d'aller
convaincre maintenant les électeurs que
ça vaut le coup de voter pour lui plutôt
que pour l'extrême droite est de battre
et de serveurs de son bulletin de vote
pour l extrême mais nous on n'ira pas
plus loin parce que on se fait aucune
illusion sur ce qu'ils feront qui va se
passer dans tous les cas il va falloir
qu'on est un pôle de résistance par
rapport aux mauvais coups qui vont venir
sur constructive en appelant à août et
manuel macro pour qu'il reste président
dé la droite la droite n'est pas du
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
on voudrait jusqu'ici vous exprimer sur
ce plateau la droite n'est pas au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle pour
la deuxième fois de son histoire
qu'est ce qui vous arrive la droite ne
sait plus parler aux français je sais
pas si c'est ça d'abord eric woerth et
de droite bruno le maire et de droit de
gérald darmanin de droite donc qui à
certains il ya certains l air qui sont
au second tour de curation de l'élection
de l'élection présidentielle moi je
m'inscris en faux franchement contre ce
faux clivages qui essaye de créer à la
fois emmanuel macron et marine le pen
même si moi désolé cher monsieur pour la
france je pense qu'il faut quand même
mieux malgré tout un deuxième
quinquennat
je suis désolé en fait je suis désolé je
suis pour qu'on reste dans l'europe je
vois là je pense même que pour l'image
de la france je pense que élire une
présidente estampillé extrême droite
nous ferait basculer dans la deuxième
division et je ne dis pas que mais elle
m'a qu'ont fait les réformes nécessaires
pour que nous restions en première
division mais je pense que marine le pen
ll nous enterrait de manière assez des
films disiez tout à l'heure qui emmanuel
macron avait tout fait pour que oui oui
je pense objectivement c'est ça qui me
qui me en même temps me sert un peu le
coeur c'est que on se retrouve là au
terme de deux
de manigance politique politicienne qui
font qu'on a cette affiche qu'on nous
promet depuis depuis des semaines et qui
arrivent non pas après des
confrontations d'idées et de projets
mais après la mise en place de
stratégies qui font que qu'on a qu'on a
cette affiche donc je suis moi je suis
un peu triste pour la politique je pense
qu'on a peu débattu sur le fond moi j'ai
eu un débat avec jean luc mélenchon que
j'ai eu même deux débats avec jean luc
mélenchon si on avait un avant que je
rejoigne valérie pécresse un autre après
que je trouvais intéressant parce qu'au
moins il y avait une confrontation
d'idées il y avait des projets
sociétaires votre exemplaire en sciences
un fou les examens à faire ça je ne dis
pas le contraire on faut qu'on fasse un
check up complet c'est ça c'est
absolument certain moi je pense que on
n'était pas clair sur le projet de
société qu'on défend becs elle société
alternative à maquereau on proposait en
l'occurrence je pense une société plus
respectueuse des premiers de corvée une
société où les pouvoirs de le pouvoir
politique ne sachant même pas seulement
à aider les premiers de cordée
autoproclamé d'ailleurs puisque moi je
pense qu'un interne en médecine qui
travaillent la nuit pour 1800 euros il
est très largement autant un premier de
cordée que n'importe quel traders qui
votent macron parce que entre traders
macro une espèce de pléonasme donc ça je
pense qu'on aurait pu dire des choses
qui sont un cépage fautes directes c'est
la règle du jeu dans une soirée
présidentielle ayman el ma conquête en
train d'arriver dans la salle principale
de son alors c'est pas son qg c'est le
lieu où il a réuni ses militants l amont
d'un gamin est sur place pour vous faire
vivre l'arrivée
macron qui est donc en tête de ce
premier tour
et oui ça fait une heure quarante-cinq
qu'ils attendent le finaliste emmanuel
macron saoulé aura des militants monte à
la tribune il était accompagné par son
épouse brigitte macro alors il n'a pas
fondu la foule ans il est arrivé
derrière et les militants qui scandent
écouter
[Applaudissements]
et 2 et 5 ans + façon match de football
emmanuel macron le sourire il faut dire
qu'il ya quand même un soulagement de
voir le candidat emmanuel matters bien
devant sa concurrente marine le pen
emmanuel macron qui va prendre la parole
dans quelques instants
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup mes amis mes chers
compatriotes merci
mes chers compatriotes
de métropole d'outre-mer et de
l'étranger
ce dimanche 10 avril
vous avez été plus de 36 millions à
faire valoir ce droit
[Applaudissements]
ce droit conquis par les générations
précédentes et le droit de vote
et je remercie tous nos compatriotes
il dès le premier tour ont porté leurs
suffrages sur ma candidature
[Applaudissements]
leur confiance
votre confiance
aux normes obligent et m'engage
vous pouvez toutes et tous comptez sur
moi pour mettre en oeuvre ce projet de
progrès d'ouverture et d'indépendance
françaises et européennes que nous avons
défendu tout au long de cette campagne
je veux aussi
remercier
toutes celles et ceux
quelques-uns on a ici ce soir à mes
côtés il durant ces dernières années
ont tant donné partout sur le territoire
vous avez donné votre énergie votre
travail vos jours et vos nuits je sais
ce que je vous dois merci
[Applaudissements]
et j'appelle tous ceux qui depuis 6 ans
et jusqu'à ce soir se sont engagés pour
travailler à mes côtés à transcender
leurs différences pour se rassembler en
un grand mouvement politique d'unité et
d'action pour notre pays
je veux saluer l'ensemble des candidats
présents au premier tour nathalie
arthaud
nicolas dupont aignan anne hidalgo
yannick jadot
jean lassalle
jean luc mélenchon
valérie pécresse
philippe poutou
fabien roussel
eric zemmour
merci à toutes et tous ce soir une fois
encore de les applaudir merci beaucoup
parce que depuis le début est depuis
toujours nous défendons des convictions
avec force mais en respectant chacune et
chacun merci pour cela
je sais
la déception des candidates et candidats
dont je viens ici d'évoquer le nom et
celle de leur soutien en de leurs
électeurs notre démocratie en effet est
riche de tous les engagés qui défendent
leurs idées avec force et passion
merci à eux
je remercie anne hidalgo
yannick jadot valérie pécresse et fabien
roussel du monde et ce soir apporté leur
soutien
j'invite solennellement nos concitoyens
quelle que soit leur sensibilité
et quelle qu'ait été leur choix au
premier tour à nous rejoindre
certains le feront pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
je suis pleinement conscient que cela ne
vaudra pas soutien du projet que je
porte et je le respecte je sais que
c'est le choix fait par exemple par jean
luc mélenchon
je veux ici
saluer leur clarté à l'égard de
l'extrême droite et pour faire barrage à
l'extrême droite
mais dans ce moment décisif
pour l'avenir de la nation
plus rien ne doit être comme avant
c'est pourquoi je souhaite tendre la
main à tous ceux qui veulent travailler
pour la france je suis prêt à inventer
quelque chose de nouveau
on rassemblait les convictions et les
sensibilités diverses afin de bâtir avec
eux une action commune au service de
notre nation pour les années qui
viennent c'est notre devoir
[Musique]
à tous nos compatriotes
ils se sont tournés vers l'abstention
ou le vote extrême soit parce qu'ils
sont en colère face aux inégalités qui
persistent aux désordres écologiques à
l'insécurité du quotidien à la
difficulté de vivre dignement même quand
on travaille dur
soit parce qu'ils se sentent
insuffisamment représentés écoutez
associés je veux les convaincre
dans les jours à venir que notre projet
répond bien plus solidement que celui de
l'extrême droite alors peur et aux défis
du temps compter sur moi
[Musique]
car ne nous trompons pas
rien n'est joué et le débat que nous
aurons dans les quinze jours à venir est
décisif pour notre pays et pour l'europe
[Applaudissements]
voulons nous d'une france indépendante
parce que forte sur le plan scientifique
technologique et économique et militaire
agricoles et culturels
voulons nous d'une france qui par le
plein emploi et par le sérieux et
capables de financer son état providence
nos retraites notre école
notre hôpital et nos services publics
voulons nous d'une france qui relève le
défi climatique et écologique par le
nucléaire les énergies renouvelables la
sobriété énergétique et la planification
écologique
d'une france où par l'écologie les
factures de chauffage se réduiront et la
voiture électrique pour tous viendront
remplacer les coûteux plein d'essence
voulons nous d'une france plus juste
pour nos autres maires pour tout le
territoire pour notre est bien notre
hexagone voulons nous d'une france qui
face aux crises en cours et à venir
continuent à faire confiance à la
science à la raison à la compétence
comme nous l'avons fait ces derniers
mois et ces dernières années
[Musique]
je veux une france qui luttent
résolument contre le séparatisme
islamistes mais qui par la laïcité
permet à chacun de croire ou de ne pas
croire
d'exercer son culte
et pas une france qui empêche les
musulmans ou les juifs de manger comme
le prescrit leur religion ce n'est pas
nous
[Applaudissements]
je veux une france qui portent des
progrès pour chacun pour nos aînés pour
nos enfants pour les travailleurs pour
les familles pour les femmes et
notamment les mères seules pour les
précaires
pas une france de la régression pour
tous ce n'est pas nous
je veux une france il s'inscrit dans une
europe forte continue de nouer des
alliances avec les grandes démocraties
pour se défendre pas d'une france qui
sortit de l'europe n'aurait pour seul
allié que l'international des populistes
et des xénophobes
ce n'est pas nous
je veux une france
fidèle
[Applaudissements]
et
je veux une france dell à l'humanisme à
l'esprit des lumières au souffle de 1789
tels sont mes chers compatriotes mes
chers amis les enjeux du 24 avril
ce sont les choix que par votre vote
vous aurez à faire dans 15 jours
je veux vous dire ce soir que je mettrai
toutes mes forces pour convaincre chacun
que le seul projet pour le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet crédible contre la
vie chère c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet des travailleurs de
tous ceux qui sont au bord du chemin
c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet de la france et de
l'europe c'est le nôtre
je crois en nous en nous tous quels que
soient nos parcours nos milieux nous
tous
quels que soient nos origines le
territoire nous tous quels que soient
nos opinions et nos croyances nous tous
c'est cela la france
alors durant les quinze jours à venir ne
ménageons aucun effort car rien n'est
fait soyons humbles déterminé
alors convaincre chacune et chacun le 24
avril prochain nous pouvons faire le
choix d'une nouvelle époque française et
européenne
le 24 avril nous pouvons faire le choix
de l'espoir
de la france et de l'europe ensemble
10 28
[Applaudissements]
la fin
voilà pour le discours en direct des
manuels macron depuis la porte de
versailles à paris un président
rassembleur qui d'elle à son slogan ni
tous qui lance un appel tend la main à
tous ceux qui veulent travailler pour la
france pour bâtir une action commune
c'est notre devoir dit-il convaincre
évidemment les abstentionnistes qui
ensuite il ya eu la france qu'il porte
et a contrario celle que porte marine le
pen en faisant scandé à la foule c'est
pas nous et notamment cet international
des populistes et xénophobes qui
seraient vos alliés c'est marine le pen
l'emportent témoin je suis convaincu que
dans chaque mouvement ici peut être
représenté nous avons des électeurs
potentiels je pense notamment à la
jeunesse aux gens de moins de 30 ans que
j'ai croisés sur ma circonscription
pendant la campagne et des électeurs de
monsieur mélenchon qui pourrait au
deuxième tour venir à nous pour vous
allez tu es en train de répondre à ma
question je vais la reposer puisque est
ce que les amitiés le financement de la
campagne de marine le pen par banque
hongroise manque russe est ce que c'est
pas quand même un boulet au pied de
votre candidate et et c'est la question
que pose marine le pen avec cette
citation je la reprends pas mon compte
mais c'est international des populistes
en doute fait un trait en france on doit
pas l'argent à maquereau en droit
l'argent à la banque donc c'est en
france mais en plus cette année le
prévient de hongrie ya pas de russie 3 0
comment ça tout va bien comment vous
qu'en effet vous pourrez de financer
déclaré qu'il avait une banque française
d'accord comme je crois bat caussade
mouvement politique autour de cette
table sauf vous qui vous fait
effectivement financer sa part monsieur
poutine soit par la hongrie soit par je
ne sais quelle autre formation populiste
d'un autre pays du monde mais c'est très
bien de se vouloir patriotes et
nationalistes et se faire financer ses
campagnes par d'autres pays qui elles
mêmes sont des nationalistes dans leur
pays et démontre à quel point ils ont
des comportements humaniste en ce moment
même sur le front de l'est c'est très
bien continuer comme ça de toute façon
le clivage il est là il est certain vous
pourrez employés tous les maux gens que
j'ai entendu ce soir des et neuf fois
aux extrêmes droites si tu as répondu à
la question et c'est
non ce n'est pas un boulet parce que
marine le pen est prête marine le pen a
difference de monsieur macro et les
français sont ne sont pas dupes et là
pour apaiser le pays est là pour rendre
à cet état nation ça concorde nationale
voilà et les français le 5 ans entre le
débat de second tour a déjà commencé
effectivement laurent saint martin pour
bien comprendre ce que nous dit emmanuel
macron ce soir il dit j'appelle à fonder
au delà des différences un grand
mouvement politique d'unité et d'action
est ce qu'ils appellent à un
gouvernement d'union nationale un
gouvernement je ne sais pas en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que ce
rassemblement doit aller au delà des
mots et je crois que c'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire ce soir et il a raison on ne
peut pas prôner face aux extrêmes
l'unité le rassemblement uniquement dans
les urnes un soir de second tour il faut
le démontrer et on voit bien que
l'évolution du vote des français ce soit
sur un premier tour avec trois pôles
très clair qu eric coquerel a bien
présenté nécessite pour faire bloc face
à l'extrême droite de s'unir et c'est
pour ça que vous êtes prêt à intégrer la
france
c'est la princesse louise qui ne l'est
pas mais évidemment ce soir non mais
encore une fois ce qui est très clair
c'est qu'il ya un vrai clivage de valeur
au delà des seules solutions de
politiques publiques est un vrai clivage
de valeur et je voudrais vraiment qu'on
s'arrête là dessus quand monsieur le
député explique qu'il n'ya aucun
problème à ce que votre créancier à
hauteur de 9 millions d'euros s'appelle
monsieur poutine monsieur vous pendant
l'actualité actuelle il n'ya c'était
monsieur louis problème tant qu'aidant
cette histoire d'abord qu'est ce que
vous racontez ce n'était pas notre cas
l'ancien auteur de 9 buts c'est pas
monsieur poutine dans ces deux banques
avaient d'accord sûr quand je fais mon
numéro 3 de pomme avait raison ce que je
vous dis monsieur sait que matt avons
une différence je termine si vous voulez
rapidement votre disposition sorte de
seconde on voit les images des macros
bonne foule à la sortie porte de
versailles avait juste finir si vous
voulez le le clivage des valeurs c'est
pas c'est un clivage accessoires et
secondaire la question est de savoir est
ce qu on veut rester de votre bilan est
ce qu on veut rester dans un pays où
notre devise liberté égalité fraternité
et la laïcité ça c'est vrai oui mais
monsieur vous pouvez toujours dire ces
mots c'est moi c'est moi c'est moi c'est
pas gaz mans le front national a une
histoire dans ce pays monsieur le front
national de l'histoire sont en acier
vous ne ferez pas croire à quiconque ce
soir sur ce plateau que tout d'un coup
vous êtes saint fons que le parti de
l'unité et du rassemblement vous avez
toujours été serein division et dans
l'est nous voulons un débat nous avait
servi aux mondialistes et nationaux et
là ce n'est pas de dire cette phrase
mais
oui mais si vous mettez en scène des
bacs rosicky
vous devrez faire preuve d'humilité mais
c'est ce que je n'ai pas gagné et c'est
pas avec votre arrogance habituelle que
vous allez gagner encore tout à fait
prête à travailler plus cher monsieur
vous monopolisé la parole depuis une
question d'utiliser des arguments qui
excusez moi sont châtains de
rassemblement de quoi parler at in an et
vous aide si vous voulez faire réélire
macro moi je souhaite que mâcon soirée
lui parce que je ne veux pas que
l'extrait de vote soit au pouvoir il
faudra aussi faire un tout petit peu
accepté de faire votre bilan est votre
bilan on peut pas dire qu'il soit
reluisant sur tous les plans mais c'est
en jeu dans ce sens mais j'ai vu la
différence des valeurs
il ya des différences
là dessus nous sommes d'accord mais
moi je n'ai pas aimé l'attitude
d'emmanuel mâcon il devra faire quelque
chose par rapport à ça dans sa manière
de toujours essayer pour le coup de
constituer une majorité de français
contre une minorité il a très souvent
fait ça par exemple les antilles vague
c'était des demeurés des vauréens il y
avait le cercle des intelligents qui eux
étaient du côté de mâcon et ça a été
comme ça pour un peu tout donc moi ce
que je veux dire simplement c'est que si
on doit être constructif moi je pense
que l'opposition devrait être
constructive quelle qu'elle soit il
faudra que l
travailler en bonne intelligence eric
kobi faire preuve du million vélo on va
lui donner la parole cette main tendue
des manuels macron quand il parle
effectivement quasiment d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale est ce
qu'il va tourner est-ce qu'elle va
jusque est-ce qu'elle va jusqu'à macro
il a un programme qu'il a annoncé qu'ils
étendent qui en gros il annonce empire
ce qu'il a fait depuis cinq ans on est
d'accord on est d'accord oui d'accord
vous êtes d'accord aux mêmes programmes
au niveau économique et social d'accord
c'est à rallonger l'âge de l'art départ
à la retraite toujours moins d'impôts
des cadeaux aux plus riches des
politiques qui j'allais dire continuer à
casser les services publics la liberté d
à l'école le fait de donner aux
directeurs d'école le droit de choisir
leurs enseignants etc on en voit les
dégâts régler encore des plans
d'austérité en annonçant que en cinq ans
on va régler une partie de la dette que
vidic sera donc ces annonces et donc
vous comptez pas sur nous pour dire
qu'on va que on va voter positif pour 50
macro nice dont pays a souffert bon la
seule chose c'est que du coup de ses
tableaux puma mme le pen
j'ai bien du côté de la mitaine un
programme économique sociale elle a beau
dire qui est quasiment le même elle
aussi elle propose de rallonger l'âge de
la retraite elle aussi elle s'inquiète
des déficits la flf a elle aussi en
réalité à nador ans qui avait atteint
les cimes a fini à qui en parler elles
n'auront club avec eux rien donc prévu
que mick social c'est pas très différent
et en plus sa sage elle ajoute laure le
retour au droit du sang que seul le
gouvernement de vichy a fait des mesure
où elles divisent les français l'ont
prise immigrés par le diko à mistral je
fais pas
je vais pas me laisser insensible
ramdam la petite bombe
notamment pour les gens qui sont deux
choses différentes et pour l'idée d'un
pays que je veux unis j'allais dire que
la solution n'est pas encore de faire
pire mais ne comptez pas sur moi pour
dire que je vais adhérer à quelque chose
contre lequel je vais mobiliser et si
l'impasse où l'eau de passe passe rien
faire je me bible nous nous mobilisions
delà des importantes y compris à partir
des législatives ou compte bien
rassembler de manière importante manuel
vargas voilà la peine qu'ils attendent
et on s'est fait remettre à plat la
pousse à sous et là tout va dire ne va
pas une voix 3,24 pas une voix pour
l'extrême droite nous paraît être un
positionnement déjà suffisamment fort et
je suis d'accord une seule consigne va
falloir que à mon avis monsieur mac on
fasse un peu plus fort que ce qu'il a
fait ce soir là on repart dans un
discours qui ne correspond en rien au
bilan qui a été le sien et le programme
qu'il veut appliquer au pays parce que
je sois pardon
sans arrogance aucune monsieur mais à
aucun mal à ce soir vous voyez des
français des millions de français place
emmanuel macron au premier tour comme
très bien non mais comme un satisfecit
de son bilan pas parfaitement pas
intégralement nul n'est parfait on a
fait des erreurs évidemment mais à aucun
moment vous n'en parlez de cela comme si
de toute façon ce qui se passait ce soir
était soit une manipulation grossière
soit une erreur de l'histoire et soit
pour vous 2 en tout cas le fait
maintenant nous avons écouté et a fait
des erreurs mais
vous écouterez ce qui se passe dans pays
oui parce que certes les belles
m'accrocher d'accord certaines ont battu
bourg sont ce soir quand verizon sortant
mais il a une opposition qui à peu près
des trois quarts du pays mais bien sûr
j'ai commencé comme je n'ai compté 3 kg
mais comme non non non ça va
non écoutez j'ai chuté ce qui monte du
pays quand vous allez pas comprendre
pourquoi une force comme l'anneau de ce
soir va être à près de 22% dans les voix
qui porte justement fait un programme
comme c est alors qu'ils avaient jusqu'à
dans une merde aux racines de nous
laisser reprendre la main une seconde on
va retourner au quartier général enfin à
la porte de versailles en tout cas où
emmanuel macron qui arrive donc en tête
de ce premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle réunissent et ses
partisans l'ambiance elsa mondain gava
depuis quelques minutes racontez nous
eh bien écoutez emmanuel macron s
attarde il sert beaucoup demain il va
arriver du côté gauche de la scène et il
ya le gouvernement qu'il attend
évidemment pour le saluer il répond même
à quelques interviews en direct
emmanuel macron qui est monté sur scène
avec un très large sourire il faut dire
qu'il est devant marine le pen et bien
devant alors que dans les derniers jours
les sondages se rapprocher entre les
deux candidats et puis pendant son
discours est bien l'équipe de campagne a
envoyé la note le premier déplacement
des manuels macron demain ce sera dans
les hauts de france et ça ce n'est pas
anodin on le sait dans les hautes france
le rassemblement national fait des bons
scores il s'agit donc pour le candidat
de jouer projet contre projet d'aller
convaincre même sur des terres
difficiles emmanuel macron qui malgré le
sourire l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
rien n'est fait je compte sur vous at il
fini son discours emmanuel macron qui
continue les interviews avant de serrer
quelques mains jean castex et les
membres du gouvernement l'attendent à la
fin merci elsa mandingue havas nous
sommes à présent en mesure de vous
donner les intentions de vote pour le
second tour de cette élection
présidentielle 2022 intentions de vote
de notre partenaire ipsos oprah steria
avec emmanuel macron à
54%
4 % et marine le pen à 46% pierre latry
ce sont bien les blues qui ont su en
tout cas c'est votre estimation pour le
second tour avec évidemment là un second
tour qui est bien plus serré que celui
12h07 où on avait 66 % pour emmanuel
mâcon 34% pour la peine oui absolument
c'est un second tour qui s'annonce de
toute façon beaucoup plus serré qu'il ne
l'était en 2017 mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant de regarder ce sont les
reports de voix des électeurs du premier
tour et son constate notamment la
différence qui pourrait changer beaucoup
de choses c'est l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon bien sûr puisqu'il arrive en
troisième position puisque on a à peu
près aujourd'hui un tiers de ses
électeurs qui iraient sur emmanuel
macron un peu moins d'un tiers sur
marine le pen est un peu plus d'un tiers
sur l'abstention faut savoir qu'en 2017
il avait plutôt voté pour emmanuel
macron donc là on voit une différence
qui pourrait changer beaucoup de choses
dans le vote donc laissons les électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon qui détiennent
finalement avec 22% premier tour c'est
sûr de toute façon que c'est lui qui a
la réserve de voix la plus importante
c'est aussi qu'on voit que l'électorat
de yannick jadot et de valérie pécresse
irait plutôt sur emmanuel macron ce qui
n'est pas une surprise et sud eric
zemmour plutôt sur marine le pen ce qui
n'est pas encore une fois une surprise
non plus alors les chiffres qu'on a vu
c'est quoi c'était le pronostic de
victoire au second tour ses
victoires donc on demande aux français
son look qui va l'emporter au second
tour donc il répondra 58% emmanuel
macron mais ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est en fonction des électorats
puisque l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon de yannick jadot donc celui de
la gauche plus d' emmanuel macron et de
valérie pécresse pense qu emmanuel
macron va l'emporter mais dans
l'électorat de marine le pen ce qui
n'est pas très étonnant mais aussi
d'eric zemmour ils pensent ils sont plus
nombreux à penser que marine le pen va
gagner que emmanuel macron ce qui induit
quand même qu'il ya un espoir de
victoire à droite en tout cas à la
droite de la droite pour la victoire de
marine le pen
laurent saint martin ça vous rassure
vous ça vous inquiète ces chiffres non
moi je crois que le second tour être
très difficile et très serré et c'est
pour ça que quand je parle de
rassemblement c'est pas une litote et
c'est pas un mot pour faire bien voir de
premier tour on a réellement besoin tous
les républicains de ce pays de se
rassembler parce qu'effectivement le 24
au soir marine le pen peut gagner mais
ce visage républicains contre
antirépublicain si on veut c'est l'image
qui nous amène en mai ce qui va ce
pardon à la fin de l'alternance droite
gauche finalement en tout cas c'est la
suite de la re mais c'est la suite de la
recomposition politique initiée en 2010
est ça c'est sûr en revanche ce qui est
très clair et ce que vous montrez bien
monsieur c'est que les voix de jean luc
mélenchon ne sont pas que des voix il
considère le ni-ni ou qu'ils considèrent
que marine le pen peut être une bonne
présidente de la république je crois
qu'ils sont minoritaires je l'espère et
nous nous avons quinze jours pour aller
convaincre l'ensemble des électeurs qui
ont donné leurs suffrages aux autres
candidats du premier tour pour aller les
convaincre justement autour des valeurs
mais pas que monsieur parler de pouvoir
d'achat enfin pardon mais le bilan du
pouvoir d'achat il est aussi dans le
camp emmanuel macron un ami debout et a
mis le bouclier tarifaire qui a mis la
remise à la pompe qui a permis justement
à tous ceux qui travaillent de gagner
plus grasse c'est une goutte d'eau dans
le désert monsieur oui c'est pas tout
donné c'est plus que ce désarmement les
français de leur donne un choc je
méprise
là parlons sans langue de bois là où
c'est une politique entre guillemets de
droite c'est que c'est une politique qui
s'affiche pro business
et qui essaient de créer un climat
économique favorable dans le pays là où
à mon sens ça n'est pas une politique de
droite et où on trouve les limites de
cette histoire de
rassemblement de toutes les bonnes
volontés des traîtres de gauche et
d'être est de droite comme disait
rachida dati
on trouve les limites c'est que à mon
sens ce n'est pas une politique de
vraies réformes serre que j'ai pas vu
emmanuel macron augmenter le temps de
travail je n'ai pas vu baisser
substantiellement les impôts et les
charges
je ne les ai pas vu baisser les dépenses
publiques c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire je pense qu' aucun président sous
la vème république n'a dépensé autant
d'argent public qui avait le maquereau
donc c'est pour ça qu'à mon sens ça
n'est pas une vraie politique de droite
c'est une politique centriste et pour
tout les lectorats de françois fillon
s'est tournée en grande majorité vers
emmanuel macron 40 % contre 20 %
seulement pour valérie pécresse bah
c'est décevant mais ça je pense que
c'est plus à aller chercher du côté de
la campagne qu'on a fait du côté de
pécresse que dans ce que propose dans ce
que fait manuel macron ça je pense que
c'est notre échec ce n'est pas son
succès c'est son échec à l avant
non c'est un échec qui est très
largement partagé je ne dirais pas tout
ce que je pense de tout le monde mais je
pense que tout le monde n'a pas eu le
même niveau d'engagement dans cette
campagne je pense qu'il ya des gens qui
se sont un peu planqué je pense qu'il ya
des gens qui ont beaucoup penser à la
suite et pas forcément à leur famille
politique et à leur candidate et je
pense qu'il y avait moi c'est ce que je
croyais depuis le début je crois que la
politique c'est avant tout de proposer
un modèle de société de proposer des
idées de proposer des changements et là
dessus on était sur des ajustements et
sur des réformes techniques c'est pas
sur quelque chose de plus globale merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vous rappelle donc nous
notre dernière estimation pour le second
tour donné par notre partenaire ipsos
sopra steria qui donne un second tour
avec emmanuel macron alors ça ce sont
les chiffres du premier tour un premier
tour donc c'est peut-être la dernière
estimation du 1er tour voilà comme ça ça
arrive dans un dans un direct donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les amis on a le
second tour ou pas alors voila merci
pour tout arrive 54% pour un mâle marron
46% pour marine le pen sachant que
d'autres instituts donnent un écart plus
serré et ce sera évidemment à affiner au
fur et à mesure de cette soirée et des
prochains jours on va tout de suite
rejoindre le parc floral dans le 12e
arrondissement à paris tam traduit kétou
avec les partisans les fidèles de marine
le pen à vous la parole temps
oui si l'ambiance est un petit peu plus
calme que tout à l'heure quand on a
senti et dans la foule galvanisée 1 par
le score de marine le pen qui arrive
donc deuxièmes de ce premier tour quand
on l'a appris aux alentours du 20 heures
de 20h avec cette salle gonflée à bloc
les élus les militants il s'y croit on a
entendu refusé un des slogans comme
marine présidente on va gagner et
plusieurs marseillaise alors marine le
pen s'est elle exprimée peu après 20h30
et elle a eu un discours de
rassemblement adressé je les incite à
tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
emmanuel macron au premier tour les
français de gauche de droite et
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu le match
retour de 2017 mais avec un certain
nombre de différences la reine lebel qui
est plus haut qu'au premier tour de 2017
est aussi maintenant qu'elle se dit
complètement libérée de ses attaches
partisanes noter que deux meetings sont
déjà prévus dans l'entre-deux tours
l'idée pour marine le pen et de se
montrer comme la candidate et la
présidente de tous les français noter
qu'en tout cas ici le car est toujours à
la fête d'ailleurs les journalistes sont
priés de bientôt partir car c'est
l'heure de la soirée privée du
rassemblement national
merci merci tam-tam traduit au parc
floral accompagné d'aurélien budo et
puis aussi les équipes de jerry norbert
évangéliste à et gaspard flamand
j'accueille nous accueillons nos
nouveaux invités le second débat
politique de cette soirée présidentielle
sur lcp et public sénat yaël boon peavey
bonsoir bienvenue députés les oem des
yvelines philippe ballard bonsoir soit
du philippe ballard porte parole du
rassemblement national gérard longuet
bonsoir les républicains de la meuse et
patrick chesnais rebond soit êtes
président du groupe parti socialiste au
sénat il ya le bruit v on commence avec
vous score assez important ce soir pour
emmanuel macron 28% il fait 4 points de
plus qu'en 2017 et pourtant ils
appellent à une sorte de gouvernement
national il tend la main à toutes les
sensibilités quoi il ya de la fébrilité
quand même dans votre camp vous savez
c'est la philosophie du président et de
notre mouvement de tendre la main à
toutes les bonnes volontés à tous ceux
qui veulent travailler avec nous qui
partagent notre vision de la france et
qui souhaitent oeuvrer dans l'intérêt
général donc la vision du dépassement
des clivages la vision du rassemblement
c'est ça fait cinq ans que nous la
portons donc moi je salue vraiment les
mots du président de la république parce
que je trouve que c'est ce que les
français ont aussi exprimé c'est ce
qu'il souhaite il souhaite que l'on
avance ensemble et c'est ce que nous
devons faire et le réseau le président
de la république a bien évidemment
raison de tendre la main à tous moi je
voudrais également saluer la plupart de
ses adversaires qui ont très bien leur
est d'ailleurs très clairement appelé à
voter pour lui contre l'extrême droite
ça c'est très important parce que il ne
faut pas dans ces affaires-là
tergiverser il ne faut pas attendre pour
dire clairement ce que l'on doit faire
et là le ce barrage à l'extrême droite
pour moi il est fondamental et stratégie
validée mais il ya aussi la force des
extrêmes ce nouveau clivage que vous
avez vous lu est-ce que c'est pas votre
échec aussi ce soir ce rassemblement
national qui est à 23,2 pour cent
écoutez nous nous sommes en tête
aujourd'hui nous avons été aux
responsabilités pendant cinq ans moi ce
que je peux constater malheureusement
c'est que d'autres partis n'ont pas
réussi à
assurés à faire leur mue et à conquérir
les électeurs et aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous avons des partis de
gouvernement qui sont à des scores
extrêmement faible et ça c'est avant
tout ça je crois qui permet aussi à
l'extrême droite d'avoir une sorte
d'épanouissement sur notre territoire
philippe ballard votre candidate
améliore son score de 2010 est de 2
points elle est à plus de 23%
d'intentions de vote selon notre sondage
estimations de vote ipsos sopra steria
qu'est ce qui peut lui permettre de
l'emporter cette fois ci qu'est ce
qu'est la puce n'avait pas il ya cinq
ans je pense que elle-même mais le dit
c'est plus la même à la mairie elle a
énormément travaillé parce qu'on lui
avait reproché au bar venir sur le débat
de l'entre-deux tours mais son projet
économique notamment maintenant l epr
est arrivé à l'elysée avec des projets
de loi il ya vingt-deux livré concernant
aussi bien les myr assuré qu'un
référendum pour que notre constitution
soit supérieur aux jurisprudences de
l'union européenne en matière de santé
en matière de pouvoir d'achat bien
évidemment je pensais à la baisse de la
tva de 20 à 5,5 pour cent voilà et je
pourrais continuer donc aller tout à
fait prête à arriver à l'elysée à la une
réserve de voix naturelle si je puis
dire le camp des nationaux représentent
plus du tiers 35 % des suffrages mais
c'est surtout au camp de jean luc
mélenchon qu'elle s'est adressé dans son
discours c'était il y avait beaucoup de
deux marqueurs de gauge en sondant ça je
sais pas mais si on prend un électeur de
jean luc mélenchon ce soit et on lui dit
mais vous voulez la retraite à 65 ans
gérés par blackrock et par des cabinets
de conseil comme mckinsey ou bien un
projet beaucoup plus juste et équitable
comme celui de marine le pen où il est
possible de partir à 60 ans quand on a
commencé à travailler entre 17 et 20 ans
et on peut partir à partir de soixante
deux ans avec 42 annuités pour avoir le
taux plein je pense que les lecteurs de
jean luc mélenchon ne s'y trompera pas
gérard longuet on voit que la droite est
très faible ce soir puisqu'elle est sous
les 5% 5 % c'est une barre qui permet de
se faire rembourser ses frais de
campagne mais c'est quand même
par qui veut dire quelque chose ce soir
avec un parti traditionnel de droite qui
est au plus bas historiquement et
emmanuel macron qui tend la main
finalement à toutes les toutes les
sensibilités est ce que vous avez envie
les républicains de passer cinq ans
encore dans l'opposition ou es ce que
vous avez envie d'aller travailler avec
emmanuel macron
je crois d'abord que nous n'avons pas
depuis 2012 suffisamment travaillée en
profondeur les raisons de l'échec de
2012 et que nous avons prolongé une
existence qui est solide parce que nous
avons des élus locaux nous avons des
mères dfi dans le département président
de région et des députés mais nous
n'avons pas travaillé sur le fond est ce
qui est arrivé c'est que nous avons été
dans les derniers jours proprement
siphonner et d'ailleurs on sait le choix
des électeurs je respecte qui sont dit
nous ne voulons pas de marine le pen et
donc ne voulons pas d'elle donc nous
votons macro dès le premier tour
inversement d'ailleurs d'autres lecteurs
ne voulait pas et ma mère et on voter
pour marine le pen ce qui fait que nous
cibler le sentiment du vote efficace
qu'est qui ce qui devient de plus en
plus évident au premier tour de la
présidentielle fait qu'un candidat qui
n'a plus de perspective d'accéder au
deuxième tour est proprement déshabiller
dans les quinze jeux derniers jours dans
les trois dernières semaines de son
électorat cela étant cela n'excuse en
rien la responsabilité intrinsèque des
républicains nous n'avons pas travaillé
sur le fond et y compris à leurs
vis-à-vis de l'ex-président macro vous
avez de l'action du prévisionnel à
parodier des sujets sur lequel nous
aurions pu travailler beaucoup plus
utilement et des sujets que nous aurions
peut-être dû combattre plus getti le
jour de la séance et écoute votre
candidature et répète un extrait de son
discours très bien parlé c'est une femme
de qualité l'élection présidentielle
opposera donc à nouveau emmanuel macron
et marine le pen ce soir je suis
profondément inquiète pour l'avenir de
notre pays alors que l'extrême droite
n'a jamais été aussi près de l'emporter
en épargnant au premier tour les
extrêmes et en esquivant le débat
démocratique atik emmanuel macron a joué
avec le feu et fait prendre un énorme
risque à la france nous pourrions tous
en payer le prix
vous le savez j'ai construit mon
engagement politique contre les extrêmes
de droite comme de gauche je les ai
toujours combattue avec force et
constance car je crois comme jacques
chirac
que tout dans l'âme de la france dit non
à l'extrémisme
le projet de marine le pen congrès le
pays à la discorde à l'impuissance et à
la faillite sa proximité historique avec
vladimir poutine la discrédite pour
défendre les intérêts de notre pays dans
l'étang tragique que nous vivons son
élection on dirait à l'effacement de la
france sur les scènes européennes et
internationales
ainsi et malgré les profondes
divergences que j'ai martelé tout au
long de la campagne
je voterai en conscience emmanuel macron
pour empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
marine le pen et le chaos qui en
résulterait voilà on vient d'entendre la
candidate de la droite valérie pécresse
qui appelle à voter pour emmanuel macron
je vous laisse finir j'ai un long gant
va donner la parole dans un tout petit
incident patrick kanner eric ciotti n'a
pas tenu du tout les mêmes propos ce
soir et lui refuse de donner une
consigne de vote et anciens manuels
macro est ce que votre parti est en
train d'imploser c'est l'illustration de
ce que j'évoquais l'instant membres de
réflexion en profondeur et trop de
solutions expédiées a très rapidement
cela étant je soutiendrai d'aleri
pécresse et je voterai emmanuel macron
nous pas contre madame le pen que je
connais depuis toujours mais parce que
je veux la construction européenne parce
que je veux qu'on remette les finances
publiques en ordre en commençant par les
régimes de retraite et je veux assurer
l'indépendance nationale et le nucléaire
que mène même mac on découvre un peu
tardivement mais qu'il découvre moi ça
me va et je n'ai pas entendu cela du
côté de madame le pen patrick kanner la
situation du parti socialiste ce soir a
des similitudes avec celle du parti et
l'air votre candidate selon notre
dernière estimation fini sous la barre
des 2%
1 8% des des voix c'est une estimation
mais de toute façon elle sera très très
faible et derrière jean lassalle fabien
roussel et même nicolas dupont aignan
c'est un échec personnel d'anne hidalgo
c'est là aussi un manque de travail de
votre famille politique du cas c'est la
démonstration que le vote utile a
fonctionné à plein ce soir très
concrètement puisque il vous aura pas
échappé que les trois premiers sont à 20
% et + et qu'ensuite on descend en
dessous de 7 ou 8 % voire même en
dessous de 5 pour la majorité des
candidats donc les français ont choisi
le rassemblement chacun de leur côté
alors ceux qui pensaient voter zemmour
ont finalement voté le pen ce qu'ils
pensaient beauté pécresse ont finalement
voté macron et nous une partie notre
lectorat a manifestement voté macron
pour justement faire barrage des
premiers tours à le pen et ou à voter
mélenchon pour éviter le jour sans fin à
savoir le même quelle conséquence nous
en tirer du coup pour le parti
socialiste ce soir s'ils voulaient je
suis pas bien ce soir j'ai je garde le
sourire parce que je suis un homme
éternellement souriant mais je suis
triste pour ma famille politique je suis
triste pour la candidate qui a été voilà
de toul est de tous les combats qui est
une grande élu national et qui
aujourd'hui porte un score extrêmement
faibles qui je crois d'ailleurs comme
d'ailleurs pour nos deux collègues
républicains ne traduit pas la réalité
de notre poids politique en français ce
qui est un enjeu financier pour nous
mais non je vais permettez moi de
continuer parce que vraiment les
finances une chose importante oui pour
l'avenir du parti sais pas mais je vais
vous rassurer là dessus si vous avez des
craintes en la matière
oui voila voila mais bon mais pour
l'instant on n'est pas encore en vente
notre local d'ivry ce que ce que je sais
c'est qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron
alors que notre soutient emmanuel macron
sera sans condition qui ait pas de
malentendu donc je voterai là aussi dans
une logique de jour sans fin et par
lassitude mais je voterai pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite et j'appelle
à tous les gens de gauche à faire de
même en la matière j'ai d'ailleurs
remarquer qu un des candidats étaient un
peu plus ambigu le chercheur est très
très facilement donc ça jean luc
mélenchon bien sûr qu'ils ne voient pas
une voix qui vous marine le pen quand
même coup de maître en 2010 est pas
nouveau prendre marine le pen se veut
pas dire pour autant qu'on va pas se
donner les moyens de la signaler tout à
leur petit l'ambiguïté une petite grosse
ambiguïté mais dont la bid dont
l'intéressé est habitué donc nous nous
avons clairement appelé à voter pour
faire barrage à marine le pen avec le
bulletin macro ce qui en aucun cas nous
représente un soutien pour la politique
passée et je le dis à la présidente de
la commission des lois député dollar m
je lui dis mais
monsieur macron et les siens avaient dit
en 2017 en mai 2010 est chez moi j'ai
retrouvé les phrases naturellement mon
quinquennat sera un quinquennat qui fera
en sorte que l'extrême droite ne sera
pas présent au second tour
ce quinquennat une paire mais alexandra
peut-être plus haut niveau que connut
une autre
aujourd'hui monsieur macro pardon je les
mois mais se retrouve devant deux
extrêmes extrême droite extrême gauche
les partis de gouvernement sont dans les
choux
je dis simplement que le choix des
français aujourd'hui c'est aussi la
sanction
curieusement même s'il est en tête des
soldes et des intentions de vote pour le
second tour potentiellement mais je le
dis
vous ne vous avait pas permis aux
petites pas permis d'éliminer l'extrême
droite de ce pays je le retrait alors
l'occasion et je reviens sur d'autres
questions sur les financements nous
avons fait un prêt de 800 mille euros
qui sera remboursé automatiquement par
et tout le reste a été autofinancé bon
je vous rassure le ps n'est pas en bons
coups qui ne m'étaient pas la clé sous
la porte hier une vive et sur la
responsabilité d'emmanuel macron dans
dont la montée ou la continuation de la
montée des votes extrémiste en france ce
qui est certain c'est qu'effectivement
nous avons toute une frange de notre
population qui qui reste
dans une désespérance sociale
économique et qui qui malheureusement
continuent à se tourner vers les
extrêmes que ce soit l'extrême gauche
d'ailleurs où l'extrême-droite puisqu'on
a des scores très haut
de ce des deux côtés de l'échiquier
politique maintenant c'est le dossier sa
stratégie politique et c'est un échec
collectif
on ne peut pas tout considérer que c'est
emmanuel macron le responsable quand on
a malheureusement mais je le déplore
autant vous un ps à 2% et le patient est
républicain qui va à 5% installés mais
attend des âges nationale est absolument
mais c'est pas vrai nous ce que nous
avons porté c'est une nouvelle façon de
faire de la politique nouveau visage
dépassement des clivages
après libre aux partis traditionnels de
se reconstruire de reconstruire leur
corpus idéologique leurs cadres
politiques et 2 recond vaincre les
électeurs moi je n'y peux rien si
malheureusement ils n'ont pas réussi à
convaincre les électeurs aujourd'hui
nous nous avons quand même un socle qui
reste très solide des lecteurs avec 28%
qui nous ont fait confiance aujourd'hui
et notre responsabilité c'est de
continuer à élargir à se voiler les
intentions de vote seront tournés ce
soir 56 pour emmanuel macron 44 pour
marine le pen s'était 66 cela concerne
46 part deux 7es 66 34 en 2000 en 2017 m
10.2 et là on est au soir du premier
tour on va laisser faire cette campagne
du deuxième tour on a quinze jours pour
faire campagne on appelle au
rassemblement
on va démonter un par un le programme de
l'extrême droite pour montrer que ce
n'est pas la solution qui va permettre
aux français de s'en sortir moi je vois
vous rappelez peut lier tout à l'heure
que vous aviez 20 programme précis pour
22 excusez-moi 20 et 22 livres et bien
moi j'ai regardé celui qui concerne la
défense page 10 il est indiqué ouvrez
les guillemets il sera recherché une
alliance avec la russie la sécurité
européenne ne peut exister sans elle
c'est écrit noir sur blanc dans un des
22 livré que vous présenter aujourd'hui
au suffrage des français alors moi je
sais pas si vous vous continuez
aujourd'hui validé ces phrases là compte
tenu de la guerre en ukraine compte tenu
de la guerre en europe compte tenu des
massacres et des crimes de guerre qui
ont lieu mais si vous continuez à
valider ce type de politique étrangère
et de politique de défense pour la
france mais vous êtes complètement
déraisonnable et vous vous dise crise y
est mais ont tous vers le pilot la
réponse des filets bat laon j'ai des
manuels macro où on part du mali je
pense à nos militaires qui se trouvent
sur mes respects des mots ces conditions
c'est pouvant ça aussi sur la russie
mais
2010 ne voulait révéler arrimer la
russie à la france et à l'union
européenne
c'est bien il continue de parler à au
président pour avoir
bâti qu'est ce que vous faites vous
envoyer des armes vous envoyer des
troupes en ukraine et ont déclenché la
troisième meilleur gagne et c'est ce qui
est désastreux vous savez on a des amis
qui viennent du liban en voyage d'étude
les libanais ne veulent plus voir
emmanuel macron on se souvient au mois
d'août il ya un an et demi quand il
était allé sur place on sait quasiment
dit d'ailleurs un protectorat français
aux livres neufs ton matin bleu
n'y ait pas cet avis si étrangère que
mènera marine le pen sera it we distance
de moscou et de washington vous allez
mettre la russie dans le passé ces
débats dans un tout petit instant
au qg des manuels macron qui se trouve
porte de versailles ce soit l amende à
gaza vous êtes aux côtés christophe
castaner qui est le président du groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
exactement emmanuel macron et devant
bien devant marine le pen pour vous
c'est déjà un soulagement ce soir s'agit
pas d'un soulagement mais une
satisfaction de voir le candidat alors
président de la république voir
conforter le score qui défait 5 ans et
être aujourd'hui celui qui peut
rassembler rassembler tout ce qui n'est
pas l'extrême droite dans notre pays on
le voit dans celles et ceux que se soit
exprimé ce soir parmi les 11 autres
candidats il ya un message clair de
soutien emmanuel macron ou de barrage à
marine le pen quand seul eric zemmour a
appelé clairement à soutenir marine le
pen n'y a pas de surprise ils sont l'un
et l'autre les deux faces d'une même
extrême droite il ya déjà des sondages
de second tour on parle peut-être de
54,46 on voit qu'on n'est pas du tout
dans le même écart qu'en 2017 pour vous
comment convaincre qu'elle est la
stratégie pour cet entre deux tours
sachant que maintenant on va être projet
contre projet un projet pour la france
où un projet contre la france et c'est
simple nous allons pouvoir dans ces
quinze jours rentrer dans le fond des
sujets marine le pen a fait une campagne
en se drapant d'une cape de banalité
pour cacher ce qu'elle est réellement
est ce que oui ou non elle veut se
battre pour l'environnement si je prends
les propositions qu'elle fait par
exemple c'est la fin de la totalité des
aides sur la production d'énergies
alternatives pour nom d'un 100% vers le
nucléaire qui n'existent pas
techniquement aujourd'hui dans les
années qui viennent c'est par exemple
sur l'europe est-ce que marine le pen
est pour ou contre rester en europe ou
dans l'europe qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit
andy a donc je veux rester dans l'europe
et en même temps dans son programme l
annonce par exemple n'y a plus de
financement est les baisses de 5
milliards au niveau français et de la
même façon dans son programme appel à
une alliance des nations et donc oui
clairement elle veut la fin de l'europe
moi je pense que nous sommes à un moment
nous avons besoin au contraire de plus
d'europe d'une france forte mais dans
une europe puissante en 2017 emmanuel
macron avait promis de tout faire pour
que l'extrême droite bien soin des
scores moins importants voit que cinq
ans plus tard il n'a pas réussi ce que
c'est un échec est ce que vous porter
aussi une partie de cette responsabilité
là vous savez une chose est sûre c'est
qu'il ya des combattants contre
l'extrême droite et je fais partie de
ceux là emmanuel macron a fait partie de
ceux là en 2010 est le sujet qui
alimente et l'extrême droite c'était la
peur face à l'emploi et surtout face au
chômage ils ont fait reculer de façon
spectaculaire dans notre pays la
question du chômage et nous pouvons nous
mettre en perspective d'aller vers le
plan d'emplois pour notre pays il ya
cinq ans si je vous avais dit sable
mouillé pris pour quelqu'un d'assez peu
crédible et donc c'est cela la réalité
mais il yad'autres peur d'autres peurs
sur lequel le rassemblement national
search mais sans pour autant opposer de
bonnes réponses nous parlerons de la
question du pouvoir d'achat prenant le
seul exemple de l'essence elle propose
de baisser la tva mais si nous baissons
la tva et si nous revenons sur tout ce
que nous avons déjà mis en place avec
notamment le bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité sur le gaz et la baisse en
matière des sens c'est une augmentation
de 20 centimes du prix de l'essence
c'est ça la réalité donc il va nous
falloir aussi montrer la réalité madame
le pen se contente de formules de
proposition de faire plaisir à tout le
monde de beaucoup de dépenses qu'elle ne
chiffre pas et qu'elle ne finance pas
nous savons comment cela se traduira à
la fin des renoncements et des hausses
d'impôts dernière question vous parlez à
emmanuel macron va pas revenir sur cette
campagne on a parfois critiqué une
absence de campagne qu'est ce que vous
lui dites ce soir pour ces deux semaines
faut faire un déplacement par jour faut
voir tout le monde faut répondre quelle
est la stratégie mais le président sera
totalement engagé dans cette campagne et
en même temps il reste présente la
république jusqu'au bout et il entend
bien continuer à être disponible
mobilisés notamment pour rechercher un
chemin de paix à chaque fois que c'est
possible en ukraine et donc c'est dans
cet équilibre là il était lui même comme
candidat empêcher je peux vous dire
combien le regrettait aussi combien il
aime le contact avec les français dans
les villages dans les villes combien il
aime les meetings et les moments de
rassemblement
mais aujourd'hui il devait aussi assumer
ses responsabilités je crois que les
français ne lui reproche pas la preuve
le résultat et la confiance qu'ils lui
ont accordée au premier tour si beaucoup
christophe castaner de nous avoir
accordé cette interview puisque vous le
voyez derrière moi là on commence à
ranger fin de soirée ici au parc des
expositions merci elsa mandingue et
reckitt avec steven martens et puis les
génériques sont sur place on cite un peu
toutes les équipes sandra cerqueira et
cécile 6 ou est-ce qu'on a une nouvelle
estimation à proposer à nos
téléspectateurs sur lcp et public sénat
l'estimation que je vois c'est
s'afficher pour le alors nouvelles
estimations du premier tour ça ou vous
l'avez vous avais prévenu ans a évolué
au fur et à mesure de la soirée et les
chiffres safin donc on a un emmanuel
macron à 27,6 % devant marine le pen à
23 % est ce qu'on a les autres candidats
ou huit chiens jean luc mélenchon est
donc à 22,2 pour cent il arrive en
troisième position tu eric zemmour à 7,2
pour cent valérie pécresse sous les 5% à
4,8 pour cent alors ensuite on doit
pouvoir trouver yannick jadot qui lui
aussi est sous la barre des 5% 4,7 pour
cent pour le candidat europe écologie
les verts jean lassalle arrive juste
derrière à plus de 3% 3,1 pour cent
fabien roussel et à 2,3 pour cent pour
le parti communiste
nicolas dupont aignan 2,1 pour cent à
nidal go 1,7 pour cent et là on voit la
tête de patrick kanner en plateau on va
vous faire réagir dans un instant
philippe poutou 0,7 pour cent et
nathalie arthaud
0,6 pour cent patrick kanner 1,7 pour
cent pour votre candidate c'est quand le
toboggan est en route ça peut aboutir à
des chiffres comme comme cela mais est
ce qu'on peut se relever d'un score
pareil écoutez je vous dirai ça aux
élections législatives et aux élections
qui suivront derrière encore une fois je
pense que ce que nous portons en projet
politique
qui n'a rien à voir avec le propose ni
madame le pen ni monsieur macro on n'est
pas favorable la retraite à 65 ans pour
reprendre la proposition monsieur macron
on n'est pas favorable
à la voix sont d'ailleurs allés vers
jean luc mélenchon oui oui mais attendez
je conduis on n'est pas favorable à la
privatisation rampante potentiellement
du service public voilà je lui dis très
simplement de l'audiovisuel on n'est pas
favorable le conditionnement de des
aides sociales
je pourrais vous en donner beaucoup plus
encore je dis simplement qu'aujourd'hui
notre challenge c'est bien sûr le tire
les conséquences de ces résultats très
mauvais
et de considérer que la proposition
socialiste d'un parti de gouvernement
historique c'est le seul parti qui a
mené la gauche au pouvoir quatre fois
dans la vème république peut pas se
limiter à un score d'une soirée
électorale donc à nous de prouver
marquée par un ultra vote utile c'est
comme ça qu'on peut qualifier les
résultats on s'attendait à un triple
vote utile mais là il a été bien au delà
des des estimations et je vous propose
puisque celui qui a bénéficié de ce vote
utile à gauche c'est jean luc mélenchon
d'aller tout de suite au cirque d'hiver
dans le 11e arrondissement à paris
retrouvé bastien lachaud député les
filles de seine-saint-denis qui est au
micro de stéphane idée pierre
bastien la chose je suppose que vous
êtes déçu ce soir est ce que ce n'est
pas aussi de l'échec d'une union à
gauche qui l'a jamais pu être fait ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui retenir c'est le
très bon score que nous avons réalisé
plus de 22% maintenant et nous
continuons de grimper
là une grande campagne qui a su
rassembler qui a suscité de l'espoir de
la dynamique dans la jeunesse dans
énormément de catégories sociales qui
n'était pas représenté jusqu'à lors et
on le voit dans de nombreuses villes
populaires où les scores sont très très
importants le voit dans les outre-mer
donc nous avons porté un programme avec
un candidat qui a suscité l'adhésion
d'une grande partie de la population
aujourd'hui nous avons posé les bases
les nous regardons vers amiens jean luc
mélenchon n'appelle pas clairement à
voter emmanuel macron pourquoi il a dit
et répété plusieurs fois pas une seule
voie pour le
le front national les gens ont su ce
qu'ils avaient à faire en 2017 ils sont
grands ils savent ce qu'ils doivent
faire pour pas une voix pour marine le
pen il a dit tout à l'heure sa déception
mais aussi sa fierté et il a appelé à
continuer le combat la prochaine
bataille c'est les législatives est-ce
que vous l'amènerai seul ou avec
d'autres partis à gauche écoutez nous
allons voir aujourd'hui il ya une grande
force populaire qui rassemble le plus de
22% des voix qui a su susciter de
l'enthousiasmé maintenant nous verrons
ce que les autres soient de faire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec no
mercy stéphanie des pierres on parlait à
l'instant de la du parti socialiste très
faible la droite est très faible aussi
ce soir historiquement fait pour ceux
partis traditionnels vous arrivait
derrière eric zemmour gérard longuet
est-ce que ça ouvre la voie à une
recomposition à droite demain à une
union des droites en fait des questions
les chez emmanuel macron est d'abord il
faudrait qu'ils gagnent ce deuxième tour
et sa situation n'est pas si confortable
que cela vous l'avez d'ailleurs souligné
avec les écarts de voir et pourquoi
parce que c'est vrai que nous n'avons
pas fait 5 % des voix françois fillon
dans des circonstances épouvantables
était à plus de 20% et donc 15% qui ont
disparu une traction d'entrée une
fraction significative sans doute plus
de la moitié est déjà chez emmanuel
macron ça veut dire que les réserves de
son côté sont assez faibles et je pense
que avec la gauche c'est un peu la même
situation là il ya une gauche modérée
qui j'ai dit bronze président le patron
en période de guerre on va voter pour
lui parce qu'on va pas lui compliquer la
vie donc il a quand même aff assez
largement fait le plein des voix et les
sondages que vous donnez monde que
c'était car je ne souhaite pas du tout
qui s'inverse évidemment mais cet écart
est faible ça veut dire qu'il va
gouverner difficilement et que préparer
les élections législatives président
caennais revient de le dire c'est une
affaire importante et je me retourne
vers excellente député des yvelines
il va falloir coexister intelligemment
parce que si on coexistent
intelligemment c'est ce jeune homme qui
va ramasser les qui va exister
intelligemment ça veut dire bien veiller
ensemble assez d'ailleurs relativement
simplement ne pas se détruire et
le l'élection au scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours exige de pouvoir se parler et
si l'on ne se parle pas on prend des
risques considérables avant d'entrer
discours part d'ombré de cette caf
emmanuel macron dans son discours il
améliore très clairement tendu la main
oui les forces du oui ongrais oui mais
ce serait mieux s'il y avait un système
politique plus ouvert qui pourrait
concilier la france avec les démocraties
parlementaires européens justement jeudi
la crise on la constate que nous les
seuls présidentialiste au scrutin
majoritaire dans toute l'europe est ce
qu'une coalition vous semble possible
gérard longuet j'ai envie de dire si un
certain nombre de points sont discutés
comme savent le faire les allemands ils
mettent trois mois faire une négociation
et là on dirait en appâtant
l'accroissement en
acadie
les gestes comme et après lequel tous
les détails c'est des centaines de pages
méthodes de qualys vous dire si je pense
qu'effectivement mal de travailler
ensemble à vent et on voit des gens
assez différent pouvoir coexister
utilement pour le pays le régime
parlementaire je t'en ai raté quatre ans
en voie d'être réélu je le pense
profondément
je souhaite qu'il le soit le rappelle
que c'est son deuxième et dernier mandat
donc il faudrait peut-être songer un
système hydraulique des estives en
fonction des instituts sont des
déclarations
emmanuel macron c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre derrière la main tendue en
tout cas moi ce que ce que l'on souhaite
c'est travailler le plus avec la
majorité la plus large possible avec
ceux qui partagent notre vision et je
vous entends des tout à l'heure vous
parliez d'europe vous parliez de progrès
vous a parlé d'emplois parler de la
valeur travail vous parliez de l'énergie
tout ça on le partage donc évidemment
qu'on peut réussir à travailler ensemble
vous savez vous me connaissez bien à la
commission des lois pendant cinq ans
j'ai eu un travail très respectueux
également exactement très respectueux
des oppositions très respectueux pour
essayer de parvenir à des accords à des
points d'accord de consensus parce que
je pense que c'est ça qui est bon pour
les français on n'a pas raison tout seul
ce qui est important c'est de réussir à
réfléchir ensemble les deux valeurs moi
j'y suis pas exactement du rêve le flou
général philippe val n'a pas beaucoup
parlé depuis quelques minutes alors est
ce que finalement quand vous voyez quand
vous voyez c'est est en train de se
mettre en place la voilà les discussions
les hypothèses de coalition c'est pas un
atout pour
marine le pen finalement en fait en
écoutant ce ce débat je veux dire c'est
un peu le vieux monde en fait parce que
maintenant vous lisiez iliad en france
est un vieux
beaucoup et qu'on essaye de défendre
parce que
il ya les mondialistes d'un côté et puis
il y a les nationaux les patriotes que
les souverainistes d'un côté et en fait
c'est un peu du 3 contre 1 parce que
vous incarnez ce qu'amd et des
mondialistes vous nous avez vendu tout
ce soit nicolas sarkozy
la mondialisation ans avant la bêta 1a
veritate pour des millions de français
chef d'entreprise d'ailleurs comme
salariés voient la marine le pen un
autre projet est ce qui vient de se
passer crise sanitaire crise
internationale démontre qu'elle a fait
le bon constat est calé le bun soleil
c'est à dire non pas si tout le monde
quand j'entends emmanuel macron quand
j'entends emmanuel je relisais son
allocution du 12 mars 2020 précisément
quand il nous dit quand il nous dit on
est en guerre on va être confinés et
s'interroger est ce qu'on n'est pas allé
trop loin dans la mondialisation pouvait
appeler marino peine à lui aurait donné
la réponse et nous parler de
souveraineté alimentaire de souveraineté
sanitaire parce qu'on avait le doliprane
est fabriqué en chine a semblé un en
année est exportée en europe et on a
failli en manquer ça c'est votre monde
mais ses autres moteurs c'est à tomber à
3 ème siècle
et qui ont été servis avant arrêtés nous
vendre l'europe qui protège c'est juste
pardon je vais être heureux c'est une
fumisterie voilà c'est le change assuré
moi j'ai bien compris votre projet
l'europe voulait rester voulait en
sortie non on veut ya un groupe européen
qui est en passe de se constituer qui
sera d'ailleurs le deuxième groupe au
sein de l'assemblée du parlement
européen qui sera le groupe des
nationaux on va changer l'europe de
l'intérieur voilà comment
je pas d'accord non sur pas mais on je
rentrais chez nous
on va réduire marine le pen l'a dit on
et contributeur net et on va
effectivement réduire la famille et à la
solidarité ouidah la célérité margaret
thatcher ton dvd se lève et on est quand
même des cours des rich wilson
irakien s'est d'abord et qu'on vous avez
des grands discours grandiloquents sûr
il faut se priver
regardez juste des conséquences pour les
français qu'ils disent le 10 du mois se
demandent comment ils vont finir ce même
mois voilà
j'avais déjà
de jeunes retraités que nous avons
maintenant on fait pour l'exclure de
l'énergie moi je suis ma vaisselle à
l'eau froide et là je me suis dit on en
2022 pour l'accession en pro est
président c'est de la faute de l'europe
abbey ça nous a quand même mis ça nous a
mis en concurrence il vend non mais
attendez on nous a mis en concurrence
avec des pays qui n'ont pas la même
règle les mêmes règles fiscales sociales
environnementales
très mal mais si vous êtes responsable
de tout ça madame de la graine votre
celi on attend dé moi je suis en train
de voir des amours dualisation heureuse
que vous nous avez vendu que vous
mélangez mais emmanuel macron en 2017
voulait faire des réformes pour que l'on
soit encore plus en concurrence qu'on
soit mieux armées pour lutter contre des
pays qui n'ont absolument aucune règle
semblable au nôtre mais c'était oui il
s'est fichu des français alors je
voudrais donner la parole à des caméras
et notamment pour réagir au discours de
marine le pen ce soir qui a vraiment
employer beaucoup de termes qui sont des
termes qu'on entend souvent chez les
candidats de gauche protection sociale
c'est les premiers mots qu'elle a dit
dans son discours elle a parlé ensuite
de défendre les personnes face au poids
de de l'argent les thématiques
traditionnelles
du parti front national plus
rassembleuse nationale et immigration et
sécurité sont arrivées bien bien bien
mais est-ce que c'est fait normalement
elle la première candidate de gauche
jean simard de fumisterie permettez moi
l'expression riba oui enfin je veux dire
que chacun sait quel est le programme
qui a été évoqué par exemple par les
autres bleus peinent dans le pen c'est
un danger pour la démocratie c'est là
une histoire elle a une histoire pour
expliquer
ces les éléments mais chez ballard vous
ferez vous ferai campagne contre
l'oppression de madame de chez makro
mois pour ce qui me concerne je défends
une position permanente de lutte contre
l'extrême droite dans sa ligne droite
mais c'est pas chaud c'est pas choquant
d'être de l'extrême droite puis dire
comme il ya comme je veux leur show et
de l'extrême gauche ça fait partie de
l'histoire de notre pays ce que je
considère aujourd'hui c'est que madame
le pen se veut être le chantre la
défense des petits mais ces deux mais
n'a aucun moyen pour le faire et
sacrifiera l'économie française sur
l'autel finalement d'une idéologie que
nous combattons et que nous continuerons
à combattre donc quand j'entends le che
ballard ce soir je me dis j'ai eu nous
avons eu raison de la portée
immédiatement notre soutien à monsieur
macro par contre je le dis à madame
brand vivait en aucun cas c'est un blanc
seing
en aucun cas nous cautionnons le bilan
qui a été le vôtre qui amène aujourd'hui
les extrêmes à être au plus haut dans
notre pays au plus haut dans notre pays
donc nous considérons que vous avez
fauté néanmoins sans conditions nous le
ferons parce que entre le programme que
nous allons combattre démocratiquement
celui que vous allez peut-être porter si
vous êtes élu quand ils vous votre parti
et les sept autres formations politiques
ce qui ne m'a pas échappé il y avait
huit formations politiques aujourd'hui
qui appartenait à la macro ni souhaite
bien du plaisir pour les investitures
aux législatives
un autre débat entre votre programme et
est ce que représente l'extrême droite
est bien le choix est clair nous votons
pour l'intérêt de la république et à le
brevet nous sommes soir du premier tour
il reste qu'un jour avant le 24 avril
est ce que c'est une nouvelle campagne
qui commence aujourd'hui
et quelles doivent être les angles
d'attaqué pour vous je crois que
aujourd'hui sur un deuxième tour on doit
très clairement être projet contre
projet il faut que nous présentions
continuant à le faire présenter notre
projet aux français ce sur quoi ce que
nous voulons faire pendant les cinq
prochaines années et combattre le projet
que présente marine le pen le démonter
montrer qu' elle n'a aucune vision est
que tout ce qu'elle propose est
dangereux pour la démocratie vous l'avez
rappelé pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français pour leur emploi pour leur
santé leur sécurité
enfin faire campagne en allemagne mais
il a fait campagne autant qu'il le
pouvait c'est ce qu'il avait dit ils
avaient cessé le front européen
international devait qu'il devait
assumer il n'a pas esquivé le débat moi
j'étais à poissy avec lui à ses côtés il
était extrêmement
disponible pour échanger il a échangé
puis à pau il a fait des sorties sur le
terrain il a eu beaucoup d'interventions
aux médias nous nous avons fait mais des
centaines de réunions publiques mois
encore avec
qui vient de normandie dans les yvelines
parce qu'on a décidé le candidat
emmanuel va qu'on va se démultiplier sur
le terrain pendant les 15 jours qui
viennent mais relégué peut-être là la
guerre en ukraine non parce qu'il faut
il faut qu'il continue à faire ce qu'il
a toujours fait il est président de la
république et candidat au deuxième tour
de la présidentielle il doit tout gérer
de front et il en est largement capable
c'est ce qu'on attend du lait français
attendent ça de lui
aussi catastrophique quand même reda
est-ce que déjà quand tu parles du
chômage premier point il membres et moi
j'invite tous ceux qui nous écoutent à
les vérifier c'est pas compliqué on va
sur le site de pôle emploi et on regarde
les cours quand il lit jamais le chômage
a été aussi bas depuis 15 ans c'est faux
5 millions 300 mille étaient 3 million
deux cent mille i à 15 heures tous les
le commerce extérieur vers les mêmes
déficit du commerce
politique et
ailleurs en matière de pouvoir d'achat
c'est catastrophique donc emmanuel
maintenant concernant c'était le mozart
des finances mais il a dû perdre ses
partitions en cours de route c'est
catastrophique l'aider la dette a
explosé 600 milliards il n'y en a que
sans qu'elle soit aussi attendu je peux
finir madaba je vous ai laissées par les
jets compte 186 milliards qui sont dues
à la lutte contre la copie très bien
longtemps qu on aurait peut-être pu
renforcer les fonds propres le reste
c'est de la mauvaise gestion 600
milliards de dettes en plus sur le
quinquennat c'est moi ou c'est faux
écoutez monsieur je pense que justement
ce qu'attendent les français ça ne l'est
pas des litanies
voilà déjà sur ce complet le plus
honnêtement possible ce que l'on
souhaite faire et c'est ce que nous
faisons il va y avoir un débat deuxième
tour
qui a déjà commencé en partie mais ce
sera cette fois avec les deux finalistes
de ce premier tour c'est le sait le plus
dur qui va qui va commencer là aussi
pour vous il ya le traumatisme de 2010
est non mais il ya un espoir parce que
déjà une open à une réserve de voix et
puis tout à l'heure vous le disiez fin
vous en parler avec notre spécialiste
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon est
très partagée ainsi un tiers un tiers un
tiers voilà à l'arrivée il ya des
instituts qui donne 49 51 vous donnez 46
54 c'est à dire qu'on est dans la marge
d'erreur il reste moins de quinze jours
il reste 13 jours de campagne ne peuvent
à faire ce qu'elle fait depuis des mois
maintenant aller à la rencontre des
français je ne fais pas emmanuel macron
sur le terrain elle écoute elle parle
aux français elle explique son programme
gérard longuet vous avez expliqué tout à
l'heure pour quoi vous à titre personnel
vous alliez voter emmanuel macron est ce
que la question de la politique
étrangère la politique de défense pèse
aussi beaucoup dans votre choix c'est en
effet un facteur important
mais le problème des manuels macron
c'est qu'il a pris des engagements pour
le deuxième c'est quinquennat et
justement ce quinquennat sera le sien et
naturellement on l'attend au rendez-vous
des trois milliards de plus par an pour
le budget de la défense qui l'a annoncé
et si l'engagement est tenu on ne peut
que s'en réjouir on ne on donne pas a
priori simplement on rappelle cet
engagement comme l'engagement sur
l'indépendance énergétique à travers des
solutions pertinentes comme le sont le
renouveau comme les pardons le renouveau
du nucléaire n'est pas uniquement d'un
jeu les emmanuel macron c'est bon le
bilan naturellement les projets sur le
comportement humain si vous voulez je
suis très frappé de ce fossé qui existe
avec l'autorité politique on a le sang
il ya des choses qui des drames qui ont
absurde qui aurait pu être évitée comme
par exemple et gilet jaune qui sont très
largement un profond malentendu et moi
ce que je souhaiterais un système
politique où en effet on puisse se
parler on puisse négocier et où il n'y
ait pas cette ce système vertical qui
fait qu' on attend la décision du shérif
ont été présentés la vème république il
faut la faire évoluer vous avez raison
ce plateau pour ce deuxième débat
politique et nous partons au qg des
manuels macron se trouvaient les armes
ont un gave à elsa vous êtes aux côtés
de clément boon qui est le ministre
chargé des affaires européennes
exactement on a senti dans les derniers
jours beaucoup de stress dans la
majorité finalement quel est le
sentiment ce soir un soulagement de la
gravité malgré tout il ya une gravité
mais il ya une fierté parce que
regardons le score de ce premier tour
mais le maquereau est en tête nettement
il améliore son score par rapport à
celui de 2010 est malgré cinq ans de
responsabilités avec des crises
difficiles donc je crois que c'est un
bon score qui nous donne la force pour
avancer mais il ya des éléments
évidemment qui sont préoccupants pour
notre pays sur le plan démocratique une
extrême droite ce qui reste forte marine
le pen eric zemmour marine le pen qui a
progressé aussi par rapport à 2010 est
il y à une abstention qui reste
importante donc c'est un combat qui
commence pour les quinze jours qui
viennent qui est totalement différent il
faut le mener avec la conviction qu on a
ce socle pour rassembler pour avancer
avec la clarté aussi que je salue de
beaucoup de candidats qui ont appelé ce
soir a voté contre madame le pen ou pour
emmanuel macron ce qui est encore plus
claire et encore mieux maintenant c'est
la bataille seconde après seconde
te ment pour ces deux semaines elles
sont où vos réserves de vote elles sont
chez les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
qui on le voit talonne marine le pen en
troisième position mais elles sont chez
tous les français y compris chez les
électeurs de marine le pen parce que
maintenant se joue l'essentiel qu'est ce
qu'on veut pour notre pays et ce qu'on
pense qu'avec marine le pen la france
serait plus forte ou moins forte pour
moi la réponse est très claire c'est une
france qui serait rabougri replier et
qui ne pèserait plus en europe vu toutes
les incohérences de marine le pen sur ce
sujet c'est une candidate qui a le
slogan du pouvoir d'achat la bouche mais
aucune mesure qui fonctionne réellement
nous on doit montrer qu'on a un projet
positif protecteur européen sociale et
de justice c'est comme ça qu'on veut
c'est pas en faisant le le pot pourri
des des propositions des uns et des
autres c'est en s'adressant à chacune et
à chacun leur disant regardez ce qui va
se passer pour la france pour les cinq
prochaines années on choisit l'essentiel
au second tour sur la manière de faire
campagne on a reproché à emmanuel macron
de vouloir en jambes et quasiment cette
campagne il s'est déclaré très tard il a
été président il a fait peu de
déplacements refusé de débattre avec ses
autres adversaires est-ce que là il faut
changer aussi cet esprit autre campagne
à les convaincre allez débattre
peut-être davantage mais ça vous a pas
échappé il ya une campagne sous
contrainte d'abord celle de la coved et
puis surtout celle de la guerre sur
notre continent le président quand il a
dit président et jusqu'au dernier quart
d'heure ce n'était pas une formule
théorique ou un exercice de style c'est
la réalité quand vous avez la guerre en
europe des sommets européens menés et a
présidé cette action diplomatique et
cette action de sanction à construire ça
prend du temps et donc le candidat
macron j'en suis sûr aurait aimé en
avoir plus pour être présent sur le
terrain déployer encore davantage le
projet il l'a fait autant qu'il a pu les
ministres les militants se sont relayés
je crois qu'on est la formation
politique qui a fait le plus de réunions
politiques depuis maintenant à moi et
puis maintenant c'est projet contre
projet et candidat contre candidat donc
oui je suis sûr et dès demain d'ailleurs
le candidat mais le macron sera sur le
terrain au contact dans l'explication
dans le débat bien sûr et nous aussi ses
soutiens en relais mais on verra le
candidat je vous rassure et on a quinze
jours avec du temps de parole avec du
temps de présence habitants de débat qui
va être ce moment de confrontation
politique merci et beaucoup clément
bonne et comme vous l'avez dire emmanuel
macron sera en déplacement dans le nord
demain le nord une terre où le
rassemblement national est très haut
merci elsa mandingue à va il est 23h une
sur lcp et public sénat la soirée
électorale se poursuit premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec notre
débat d'experts à présent et nous
accueillons sur ce plateau béatrice
giblin bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes géographie directrice de la
revue hérodote et puis erwan lecoeur
bonsoir vous êtes sociologue politologue
et spécialiste de l'extrême droite à
chaque oeil également martial foucault
le directeur du cevipof bonsoir martial
bonsoir bienvenue et merci d'être avec
nous et pierre latry qui nous
accompagnent évidemment pendant toute
cette soirée électorale
chef de groupe
l'institut ipsos qui nous accompagne
pour cette soirée qui sera aussi la 24
pour nous donner des estimations dès 20h
pour la victoire emmanuel macron
reconduit ou pour la première fois une
femme présidente de la république et ce
serait marine le pen on va revoir
ensemble les estimations vous nous avez
proposé elle évolua sont pas forcément
les mêmes moi je vais aller découvrir en
même temps que vous passez qu'elle
vienne de de bouger les estimations du
premier tour de cette élection emmanuel
macron à 27,6 % arrivent en tête et il
progresse par rapport à son score d'il
ya 50 tout comme marine le pen qui est
ce soir à 23% des suffrages exprimés
en troisième position jean luc mélenchon
avec 22,2 pour cent des voix tuer eric
zemmour à 7,2 pour cent et valérie
pécresse
4,8 pour cent
yannick jadot lui aussi sous la barre
des 5% 4,7 jean lassalle arrive juste
derrière à 3,1 fabien roussel 2,3 pour
cent pour le candidat communiste
nicolas dupont aignan 2,1 pour cent a ni
delgo 1,7 pour cent philippe poutou 0 7%
et nathalie arthaud ferme la marche avec
0,6 pour cent et donc pierre latry vous
avez vos estimations projections sur le
second tour de cette élection
présidentielle oui absolument une
intention de vote ipsos sopra steria
donc nous avons réalisé après 20 heures
une fois les résultats du premier tour
connu des français et qui donne un
second tour avec 54 % d'intentions de
vote pour emmanuel macron contre 46%
pour marine le pen on a d'autres
instituts qui sont qui sont plus serrés
que vous voilà on le signale parce que
évidemment c'est de cet important
certains donnent un écart 51 49 si on va
rentrer un peu dans les
dans d'autres critères quand vous posez
la question qui va l'emporter selon vous
c'est ça le vxo nautique de victoire
soto qui va l'emporter alors une
majorité de français 58% estiment que ce
sera emmanuel macron mais ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est que le
pronostic victoire en faveur d' emmanuel
macron il est fort évidemment chez ses
électeurs mais aussi chez ceux de la
gauche et chez ceux de valérie pécresse
en revanche auprès des électeurs de
marine le pen et d'eric zemmour il ya un
plus fort pronostics de victoire pour
marine le pen ce qui veut dire que il ya
encore un espoir clairement
chez les électeurs de marine le pen et
d'eric zemmour que cela la droite
nationale en fait l'emportent au second
tour contre emmanuel macron est-ce que
vous avez les motivations du vote qu est
ce qui ne ferait que les électeurs se
déplacerait aux urnes au second tour les
motivations entre marine le pen et
emmanuel macron elles sont vraiment très
différente en fait en tout cas pour ce
qui était du premier tour on a vraiment
deux façon de raisonner un petit peu
différente emmanuel macron c'est un vote
avant tout sur la personne du président
c'est parce qu'ils ont confiance en lui
c'est parce qu'il considère qu'il peut
gérer les crises est vraiment une la
question de la présidentialité de l'agît
capacité à gérer des crises qui est le
premier élément le plus cité quand on
leur demande pourquoi une votre épaule
emmanuel macron al'inverse pour marine
le pen c'est avant tout une proximité
avec ses idées et le sentiment que elle
va changer les choses et qu'elle a de la
compréhension pour les problèmes des
français merci à pierre pour ses
explications va écouter régulièrement
jusqu'à la fin de cette soirée
électorale les déclarations principal
des candidats je vous donne la parole
juste après c'est promis on réécoute un
extrait du discours d' emmanuel macron
plus rien ne doit être comme avant
c'est pourquoi
je souhaite tendre la main à tous ceux
qui veulent travailler pour la france je
suis prêt
inventer quelque chose de nouveau
ont rassemblé les convictions et les
sensibilités diverses afin de bâtir avec
eux
une action commune au service de notre
nation ou les années qui viennent c'est
notre devoir
on va là vous venez d'entendre emmanuel
macron qui s'est exprimé sous le coup de
21h30 martial foucault
picot voilà quatre jours puisque tu es à
matri vient de quitter ce plateau
catherine tricot vous êtes directrice
selon la revue regards merci à vous de
nous avoir rejoints martial foucault
quels sont les grands enseignements
qu'on peut tirer de ce premier tour
j'envoie j'en vois trois tout d'abord le
fait que le duel emmanuel macron marine
le pen soit de nouveau cette
confrontation est le signe que au cours
de ce quinquennat les autres forces
politiques n'ont pas réussi à
attirer à décanter ce qu emmanuel macron
avait lui-même voulu installer comme le
bloc des progressistes contre le blog
des populistes ce qui m'amène à un
deuxième enseignement malgré tout sur ce
deuxième tour on a entendu l'estimation
au d'ipsos pour le second tour je crois
qu'il faut être très prudent parce que
je dirais qu'il ya la possibilité qu'un
qu'un piège se referme sur ce cas
effectivement voulu installer vanian
macron les populistes contre les
progressistes le quand on regarde les
chiffres ce soir moi je suis frappé de
voir que le blog des populistes des
contestataires des formes les plus
radicalisées des partis politiques
représentent une majorité des voix vers
vous agrégé le vote mélenchon au wat
d'extrêmement absolument ce qui veut pas
dire que les comportements électoraux
second tour seront identiques mais ça
traduit le fait que on avait quatre
blocs en 2017 aujourd'hui ces trois
blocs et donc c'est le troisième
enseignement c'est que le parti
socialiste est maintenant et l'air ont
définitivement disparu de la scène
nationale alors attendons bien sûr les
élections législatives mais quand même
être j'irai être député sortant les
républicains dans six semaines en
campagne ça va pas être une chose très
très simple les députés socialistes s'y
était habitué depuis cinq ans donc oui
cette stratégie populiste contre
progressiste à
à pénaliser et a quasiment écarté les
partis traditionnels psl est on le dit
depuis plusieurs années mais ce soir
c'est une confirmation assez assez forte
et probablement plus forte que ne
l'espéraient même les responsables aient
l'air avant avant ce soir oui ce qui
nous a tous frappés béatrice giblin
c'est quand même je me souviens d'une
une du quotidien le monde qui parlait
des trois vote utile là c'est celle
ultra vote utile pour on n'imaginait pas
que ces trois candidats siphonne à ce
point les voix de leur camp c'est un ce
siphonnage si j'ose dire est arrivé tard
c'est à dire c'est à partir du moment où
il ya une semaine à peu près bon c'est
peut-être dire mais oui au fond il n'a
pas fait campagne le président mais oui
il est alors qu'il était monté à 30%
d'intentions de vote pour les faits
drapeau dix jours après on va dire
l'invasion de l'ukraine puis on a vu que
les choses baisser pour revenir à ce qui
était le niveau d'avant l'invasion de
l'ukraine mais dans les représentations
ils étaient à la baisse est elle oui
mais si on compare son soir 10 à 5 ans
aidé quand même mais il est au dessus du
nez quand même au dessus mais néanmoins
c'est il y a eu cette représentation
qu'il était qu'il était alors qu'il
était à la baisse et que marine le pen
était dans une dynamique et les gens
regardent aussi comme nous tous les
courbes et au fond à quelques jours près
on pouvait imaginer que ça d'escrocs azy
il y avait pour l'ong les plus anciens
le souvenir de 2002 exactement le
souvenir de 2002 donc tout d'un coup
cette campagne on disait tout était joué
façon c'est évident que ça allait être
ça prenez un intérêt un suspense qui
faisait d'ailleurs qu'on a eu une
mobilisation un peu plus forte lyon
raisonnable mais un peu plus forte
qu'elle ne l'était donc ça je pense que
ça a été quelque chose d'important et
puis à gauche il ya vraiment eu lé le
vote utile regardez fabien roussel qu'on
donnait autour de 4 4 et demi il est à 2
2 donc on jadot qu'on disait quand même
5 6 jeu peut-être il est en dessous de 5
voilà s'il y avait une chance eh bien il
fallait la jouer il fallait voter
mélenchon dont je crois que c'est ça qui
explique vraiment un vote utile à gauche
incontestablement
d'ailleurs quatre mains ça fait une
sortie tout de suite avant même
mélenchon en parlant très clairement de
la gauche comme s'ils pouvaient eux
maintenant être les seuls suffisamment
fort pour pouvoir
réorganiser et relancer la gauche c'est
quelque chose qui est importante erwan
lecoeur on a on a un
des forces on va dire d'extrême droite
moi j'emploie ce terme à 33% des voix
exprimées alors de ce premier tour c'est
presque inédit
au niveau européen non est ce qu'il ya
eu beaucoup d'équivalents récents non
déclare sorbonne vient de gagner haut la
main oui c'est vrai et gris le président
serbe vient de gagner haut la main alors
qu'il est très proche de poutine poutine
fait gagner ses alliés ailleurs en
europe et c'est une des raisons qui font
que moi je serais très prudent sur leur
issue du du deuxième tour c'est une des
raisons c'est pas la seule il y en a
d'autres je pense que une des premières
raisons c'est qu'on est dans un moment
historique en sciences politiques on
parle depuis quelques années maintenant
de la tripolarisation du champ politique
on y est c'est clair on va arrêter de
parler de la gauche et la droite si vous
voulez bien aujourd'hui ça veut dire
quoi que les partis traditionnels sont
morts pour vous oui ils sont exactement
à l'endroit où les clivages ne
fonctionne plus le ps est coupé en deux
entre tous sur tous les sujets de
société il ya plus de ps et elle est
coupée en deux sur tous les sujets de
société alors pourquoi ils survivent
localement puisque à une prime au
sortant ils survivent localement et il
ya une semaine j'étais sur ce plateau et
je vous disais on est dans un pays quand
même étrange où en gros on a trois
forces politiques qui tiennent la faire
au niveau local avec des élus des
milliers d'élus ps lr est élevé je vous
rappelle pas une dizaine de maires aux
helvètes grandes villes c'est pas
négligeable et ses trois parties sont
aujourd'hui à moins de 5% sont pas
remboursés sont en cessation de paiement
pour le dire rapidement alors
patrick kanner
mais en même temps
faire il aurait déjà vendu banon vous
avez suivi des populismes oui j'ai des
années des années ce que vous voyez les
prémices de l'arrivée du rassemblement
national au pouvoir aujourd'hui en fait
ça fait plus d'un an que nous sommes un
certain nombre d'analystes à dire
attention cette fois on elle va pas
jouer juste pour être présentes on est
plus en 2002 ça fait 20 ans moi je
faisais ma thèse le 3 mai 2002 et je
disais il pourrait être au second tour
mais c'était entre guillemets c'était
folklorique et puis le soir même à
bastille avait un monde fou et le 1er
mai il y avait un million de personnes
dans la rue regardez en ce moment
mais non seulement elle peut gagner
parce que il ya un effet de report
différentiel et d'abstention
différentiel qui va jouer il ya un effet
de anti macron qui va également se faire
sentir et ensuite je le dis gentiment
mais on a quand même une verrine vécu
une campagne absolument folle une
campagne complètement à droite et à
l'extrême droite où les reggae moore
alloués aux lièvres je le disais ici
encore aussi il a joué aux lièvres pour
marine le pen à la fin il s'effondre
effet 7% ce qu'on pouvait tout se dire
sociologiquement il ne représente rien
par contre il a parfaitement
présidentialiser marine le pen qui elle
récupère les marrons du feu donc oui
vous dites 33 % c'est ça en réalité
aujourd'hui on a trois blocs un bloc
conservateur voire réactionnaire
populiste et identitaire un bloc libéral
gestionnaire avec emmanuel macron est un
blog qui n'est pas constituée et
politiquement mais que en effet
mélenchon monsieur mélenchon essayer de
constituer on va appeler sociale
écologiste pour faire rapide et ces
trois blocs aujourd'hui ne sont pas
constitués en france ils le sont dans
d'autres pays ils ne sont pas en france
et chacun de ces blocs a réussi ou pas
apporté les réponses aux cinq grave
crise que nous venons de traverser et
malgré ses cinq crises qu'ovide climat
le vaccin le crise sanitaire ukraine à
chaque fois c'est une crise grave sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est la foire
n'importe quoi et on arrive quand même
un deuxième tour macron le pen à la fin
donc vraiment rien ne change pour que
tous jouer avec
jean luc mélenchon il n'est pas
propriétaire de son électorat évidemment
mais qui qui qui a une partie du destin
du second tour quand même entre les
mains est ce qu'il a été assez clair
dans les propos qu'il a qu'il a tenu et
je pense certains parler d'une big 8 et
faire barrage à l'extrême il serait pas
appelé à voter pour on va l'écouter
d'ailleurs terre jean luc mélenchon
puisque nous l'avons
nous savons
pour qui nous ne voterons jamais
et pour le reste
comme je voulais dit
il y a cinq ans vous souvenez vous qu'il
ya eu quelques dégâts après notre
déclaration pour qu'ils prendraient ton
les français ils sont capables de savoir
quoi faire ils sont capables de décider
ce qui est bon pour le pays jamais nous
perdrons notre confiance dans la
démocratie dom vous ne devez pas donner
une voix à madame le pen
[Applaudissements]
alors je le sais bien
je répète parce que des fois il arrive
que même quand je dis les choses c'est
comme si je ne les avais pas dit
alors je recommence à cet endroit du
film il ne faut pas donner ça le voir
madame le pen
il ne faut pas donné une seule voix à
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix à
madame le pen
voilà je crois que le message concept
parc lui a été entendue donc catherine
frécaut oui c'est assez clair c'était
assez clair pas une seule fois madame le
pen mais c'est pas ça mais ce n'est pas
un appel à voter magna macron ce qui
veut dire que la balle elle est quand
même largement dans le camp des
maniaques ombre il me sembla dans les
difficultés dans lequel se trouvait m me
kroes qui va falloir qu'ils aillent se
faire tour et les électeurs les
chercheurs qui ont l'oeil le la clé de
cette élection et marseille mais laquait
de cette élection c'est emmanuel macron
il faut qu'il aille les chercher une
campagne de second tour à gauche ce que
je pense c'est qu'il ya quand même des
éléments qui sont extrêmement choquant
pour les électeurs qui ont porté
l'emploi sur jean luc mélenchon mais
aussi sur fabien roussel ou aussi sur la
retraite à 65 ans la retraite heures
elle n'en montre pas avec celui non et
puis un salaire ou soir à peu bas très
clairement d'ailleurs on a vu quand même
les le recul des manuels macron cette
enquête chez quand il a sorti son
programme dont on n'a retenu que ces
deux éléments et aucun élément je dirais
redistributive plus égalitaire ou en
faveur de l'écologie c'est à dire les
marques des choses qui comptent sont pas
des marqueurs pour la pour l'électorat
de gauche et des choses qui sont
fondamentales et si il ne fait rien de
ce côté là il va avoir du mal il faut
qu'il convainc l'électorat de gauche
d'aller voter pour lui et ça ça elle ne
l'aura pas oui et électorales finit
quand même ou autour un peu en dessous
des 28 alors qu'il avait fait 24 % oui
mais c'est alors l'ordre ont dit oui
la droite oui est ce que est ce que
c'est un élan insuffisant pour vous
martial foucault
non je veux aussi lire le résultat de ce
premier tour comme ça en beauté dans l
année le maquereau on progresse de 4
points par rapport à il ya cinq ans mais
ces quatre
équipements à partir de ce soir il ya
une nouvelle campagne qui ce qui se met
en place je pense que le principal
enseignement que doit en tirer emmanuel
macron contrairement à ce que certains
de ses soutiens les membres du
gouvernement ont pu dire qu'il avait
fait campagne non là à partir de demain
je pense que sa première décision c'est
donnez-moi le programme pour les deux
semaines où je dois être tous les jours
mobilisé quelles que soient les
circonstances font pour pour la campagne
non mais regardez c'est un certain sens
qu'on parle beaucoup des maillots de
macron sur cette campagne mais c'est
aussi eux sont partis politiques la
république en marche at elle été très
mobilisés pendant cette campagne quelle
visibilité dans le débat les membres du
gouvernement le premier ministre donc je
pense que les choses vont changer au
cours des deux semaines alors
justement il peut pas faire campagne
seul on voit bien que là l'enjeu sur
tous les thèmes que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure il y à il ya un besoin
considérable ga presque d'une division
du travail sur tous les enjeux parce que
sinon on va reprocher manuel macron
d'heures effectivement le paratonnerre
de toutes les critiques et doit être en
capacité
moi je retiens ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure effectivement là est un vote
utile à gauche mais les électeurs de
yannick jadot qui ont préféré jean luc
mélenchon les électeurs de fabien
roussel l'ani d'algues au son des
électeurs qui d'une certaine manière
peuvent rejoindre sans trop de
difficultés emmanuel macron second tour
mais encore faut-il encore faut-il
par plusieurs des dimensions de ce que
mayola concours est proposé pour être
dans le centre que derrière la série
tout à l'heure ils ont ils ont étudié un
peu les reports de voix potentielles
évidemment on est toujours très prudent
encore une fois là dessus 10 et un tiers
un tiers un tiers un tiers de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon un
tiers vers emmanuel macron un tiers
faire marine le pen et un tiers qui ré
s'abstenir so lu ment la vraie le vrai
danger pour mails macron cento c'est de
ne pas re mobiliser des abstentionnistes
qui non seulement ne veulent pas revivre
2010cette en disant on l'a déjà on l'est
on a déjà pratiqué et aujourd'hui on ne
voit pas d'évolution dans la politique
d' emmanuel macron donc pourquoi être
simplement mobiliser sorte de vote faire
valoir
cette action béatrice giblin que
finalement les français ou les électeurs
en tout cas veulent leur revanche
puisqu'ils ont mis à nouveau emmanuel
macron et marine le pen au second tour
et ce qu'ils ont pas envie d'avoir un
impact quand qu'ils aient voté il évolue
la revanche les électeurs je pense que
c'est quand on voit ce résultat qu'on
dit les choses de cette façon ils
s'attendent à la revanche zemmour a
servi de marchepied incontestablement à
marine le pen en étant très excessifs
elle est apparue comme étant compatible
eux si vous voulez et et elle a vraiment
travaillé ça très très fort tu préfères
te ment mais dans la campagne qui
s'annonce là parce que là maintenant on
va quand même elle est beaucoup plus à
la castagne lors elle va jouer la
sérénité peut être la maîtresse baisse
par rapport à un évènement macro qui
peut être plus offensif mais là où
emmanuel macron a peut-être une carte à
jouer c'est sur le thème de l'écologie
c'est pas sur celui des 65 ans haye et
il l'a annoncé même s'il a expliqué que
quand on aura démarré tôt nous
assaillent là il peut récupérer les
cadavres il met l'accent sur l'écologie
y
est il est assez à mon avis à bilbao
pour le faire un électorat jeune qui a
voté jadot qui avait et chivu qui a voté
même
année dago il ya vraiment plus grand
chose à aller récupérer bon mec à
voleter de mélenchon mélenchon avait un
programme qui a été quand même avec une
composante écologique qui était fort
intéressant il avait bien viré sa cuti
on est d'accord m'enfin bon il avait su
le vendre comme il sait faire d'ailleurs
si vraiment dans cette campagne il
prendre j'ai à dire cette question de
façon
importante presque 113 dans cette
campagne là alors il va pouvoir attirer
cet électorat qui n'est pas forcément
hostiles à maquereau il ya toute une
haine de macron qu'on a déjà depuis le
début cela à mon avis ils iront pas ils
s'abstiendront ils n'iront pas forcément
voté marine le pen parce que il des
réflexes républicain puis ils sont pas
d'accord avec un certain nombre de ses
positions mais pour d'autres c'est tout
à fait compatible mais nous n'aurons pas
ce réflexe du front républicain
automatique comme on l'a connu en 2002
allez encore des parts d'ombré
interrompt encore des réactions depuis
les quartiers généraux ont rejointes à
mme tran huy qui était il ya quelques
minutes avec david rachline donc on est
au qg de marine le pen david rachline le
maire irène de fréjus
david rachline bonsoir votre réaction au
score de marine le pen qui arrive donc
deuxièmes mais c'est moins serré qu'on
avait imaginé dans l'après midi il a
écouté beaucoup d'humilité mais en même
temps beaucoup d' enthousiasme d'ouvrir
cette campagne avec la force que nous en
donner les français pour
en vue de ce second tour d'élection le
rivage est clair maintenant les
nationaux d'un côté les mondialistes de
l'autre je crois que mal les doubles à
la politique belle macro et a été un
ravage pour notre pays il est temps d'y
mettre un terme sur qui miser vous pour
le deuxième tour on a entendu le
discours de marine le pen s'adresse à un
groupe tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
emmanuel macron et en entendent
notamment un appel du pied à jean luc
mélenchon oui oui bien sûr à tous ceux
qui sont attachés à notre modèle de
protection sociale à ceux qui veulent
défendre notre pays dans son identité sa
prospérité sa sécurité oui je crois que
tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
emmanuel macron et qui ne veulent plus
de sa politique et qui ne veulent plus
non pas seulement de sa politique mais
aussi de la nature de l'homme de ce
mépris de cette arrogance doit pouvoir
se tourner une candidate qui aiment les
français qui veut les protéger
je crois que cela ça peut faire bien
davantage que 50% des voix c'est le
match retour de 2017 on se rappelle que
marine le pen avait eu beaucoup de
difficultés sur le débat d'entre deux
tours ou alors avec elle la leçon en
tirer il est vrai que c'est un clivage
qui est à peu près similaire pour autant
vous l'avez vu marine s'est libéré de
ses obligations partisane elle a quitté
ses responsabilités dans notre parti
politique pour pouvoir se confronter
directement aux français directement et
donc je crois qu'elle est oui plus libre
en même temps plus expérimentés je crois
que voilà le moment est venu merci
beaucoup david rachline d'avoir répondu
à mes questions
et erwan lecoeur on disait à l'instant
que le front républicain n'était pas
évident en tout cas ça ne se passera pas
comme en 2002 où il y avait eu 80 et 20
% il ya des réserves voix du côté de
marine le pen ça veut dire quoi il ya un
plafond de verre qui existe encore ou
pas non je crois que justement nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation où
ai je le dis calmement mais quand même
résolument
beaucoup de choses sont possibles il y à
une désaffiliation forte des français
vis-à-vis des clivages politiques
quarante pour cent des français
considèrent que gauche droite ça ne les
représente + 74 % des français disent
régulièrement moi c'est pas le clivage
qui me corresponde plus d'autres
clivages sont venus sur le voile sur
tout un tas de sujets sont nulles poser
de nouveaux clivages et donc de nouveau
front de combat et vous l'avez entendu
rachline fait comme l'extrême droite
essaie de le faire depuis 20 ans
maintenant ils essaient de créer un
nouveau clivage emmanuel macron airs
entraînants ce clivage les mondialistes
manuel macro appelle ça autrement contre
les identitaires pour le dire rapidement
et donc la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est que vont faire quid
des socios écologistes ce troisième pôle
qui sait que l'alternance inévitable en
france ce sont les extrêmes non c'est
pas forcément les extrêmes c'est vous
avez une tripartition très trois pôles
et le pôle centre attendait 0 dont deux
extrêmes ou plus ou moins extrèmes c'est
à dire que oui si vous considérez que
les socios écologistes sont extrémistes
mais ils ont une extrême gauche à côté
et là une façon marine le pen n'est plus
seulement l'extrême droite et c'est ce
que moore a démontré il y a pire que
marine le pen il ya zemmour est donc si
on si on le dit un peu comme ça
aujourd'hui les choses ont et c'est pas
qu'en france mais et dans le monde
entier ça veut dire à moins de le coeur
que la question de la poutine ofili ou
du financement russe voilà de même md
des hypothèses de politique étrangère de
marine le pen si elle devenait président
de la république ça ne pèse pas d'après
vous sur ce qu'on l'a très bien vu dans
le débat vous avez ça y
vivait tout à l'heure c'était ça c'est
très bien autre côté c'était mckinsey la
la ça marche à paris c'est bizarre et
c'est dommage ça marche pas on grille ça
ne marche pas en serbie oui ça ne marche
quasiment nulle part ailleurs au monde
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est que la morale ne fait plus de
politique ouais on fait plus de
politique avec de la morale que se
souvient face au front national il n'y a
plus de morale politique sur le thème
attention c'est le danger c'est le
monstre et ses baisers but malgré les
images de guerre de massacre bien sûr
mais pascal thiery il a été réélu haut
la main hörmann à ce qu'il a promis la
paix le gaz et le pétrole excusez moi
les français les gilets jaunes ont fait
on fait des tenues des emplois pour le
gaz et le pétrole vous n'allez pas me
dire que la morale va guider le vote où
le non vote parce que comme ça a été dit
c'est l'abstention qui va venir
déterminer c'est ce que j'appelle
l'abstention différentiel sarkozy en
2012 gagne face à ségolène royal qui
n'arrive pas à rassembler son camp mais
il gagne 1 pour lui gagne contre ségo
qui n'arrive pas à rassembler son camp
la fois d'après c'est hollande qui gagne
parce que sarko on n'arrive pas à
rassembler son camp et macron vient au
milieu et dit bah écoutez je vais vous
mettre d'accord gauche et droite vous
n'existez plus et moi je gagne parce que
vous n'êtes plus capables de rassembler
votre camp qu'est ce qui est en train de
se passer potentiellement cette fois
c'est que si jamais emmanuel macron on
avait pas de stratégie de campagne si
jamais il ne pensait pas faire vraiment
campagne parce que quelque part
président de l'europe etc ça suffisait
et bien s'il n'y a pas de stratégie il
va tomber dans le piège le piège il est
nickel c'est un référendum pour ou
contre macron et dans ce référendum pour
ou contre macron je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans les groupes
qualitatif et j'imagine au cevipof
également et ailleurs également on voit
bien qu'il ya une colère qui n'est pas
du tout je gueulais qui restent toutes
les crises que je peux dont je parlais
tout à l'heure en ti'pass sanitaire anti
vaccin anti qu'ovide anti gilet jaune
steel mais de 50% l'écologie ça fait
potentiellement plus de 50% en tout cas
de gens mobilisés un deuxième tour soit
pour voter contre macron soit pour ne
pas voter pour sauver le soldat macron
ça peut faire en effet bien tout simple
merci aux communes le pen a adouci
image est ce que dans l'est pour les
électeurs elle peut représenter la
nouvelle droite
non je pense pas qu'il y aurait une
mobilité jédir venant du camp d'une
gauche contestataire
considérant que marine le pen représente
une opportunité pour installer une
personne qui viendrait déboulonner en
quelque sorte et j'emploie à dessein ce
terme le représentant d'élite fatalement
corrompu si on reprend un discours mais
je rejoins erwan lecoeur sur un point
c'est à dire que quand on dit la morale
n'a plus son rôle dans la politique
c'est clair que au second tour qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure de coalition anti
macron c'est une polarisation très
affective le poids du ressentiment le
rôle des émotions dans le vote va peser
davantage que toute forme de rationalité
de compréhension des existe occident la
mobilisation d'un camp anti l'open
beaucoup moins nous on avait observé que
sur ces questions des émotions la colère
mais c'est un puissant 800 accélérateur
du vote pour l'extrême droite d'ailleurs
en france en allemagne au moment de
l'afd la ligue du nord en italie et
également pour le vote trump donc je
crois que dans cette campagne il va
falloir aussi probable entrée vraiment
surveiller quelle le rhétorique va être
utilisée est ce qu emmanuel macron va
sur une confrontation et suscité de la
colère chez des français qui vont
conserver qu emmanuel macron ne respecte
pas son adversaire et sage je dirais que
là on n'est pas à l'abri effectivement
de surprise parce que le poids du
ressentiment c'est ça qu'on parle de
coalition anti macron qu'on dit tout
sauf mâcon comme il ya vu avec tout sauf
sarko me laisse jouer au contraire la
carte du rassembleur dans son discours
sera entendue chez soi il fasse il cite
les 11 autres candidats en vendant à ses
partisans de les applaudir mais vous
savez aussi qu emmanuel macron a eu
l'occasion à plusieurs reprises
d'exprimer des mea culpa et puis ensuite
peut être venir
je crois que le vraiment cette cette
grammaire et bottines va être très
intéressante à surveiller pendant les 15
prochaines béatrice giblin il ya deux
france qui vont s'affronter au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle
oui d'auron scène duel comme celui là on
va avoir
des antilles macro et des pros macron
pas forcément par adhésion mais par
réflexe d'éviter à ce qu'on ait marine
le pen présidente de la république alors
qu'il y aura un beau coup plus un vote
d'adhésion je crois chez ceux qui
voteront marine le pen il est suivront
beaucoup plus que chez makro ce sera un
vote de raison non on peut pas élire
marine le pen je mettrais juste un bémol
sur la question de l'émotion tout dépend
quand même aussi comment les choses vont
évoluer en ukraine le pire est sans
doute encore devant nous mais vous
croyez que ça a joué dans cette région
sont produits en même temps que c'est
pas le pouvoir d'achat qui a pris le
dessus il y a le pouvoir d'achat mais
j'ai à dire des atrocités les massacres
ce qu'on voit vraiment sur les chaînes
de télévision surtout les chaînes en
continu et c'est une c'est une émotion
qui va falloir prendre en compte aussi
souhaité pour l'instant on a
l'impression que ça ça va rester là bas
et puis que bon nous il nous arrivera
pas grand chose la dureté de ce qui est
en train de se passer et quissac et qui
ça grince camp quand jean yves le drian
dit le pire est à venir il faut
l'entendre c'est pas il dit pas ça comme
ça en l'air 1 et moi je pense que dans
quinze jours vous savez il ya des choses
qui peuvent se passer sur ce terrain là
alors ils peuvent être très secondaire
par rapport à des élections
présidentielles où c'est lé problème
franco français c'est mon pouvoir
d'achat mais regardez aussi l'attitude
des français dans l'accueil des réfugiés
et ukrainiens
comment ils se sentent très occupé et
est on vraiment le désir d'accueillir
c'est quelque chose qui était tout à
fait inattendue moi je galérais pas
aussi vite celle ci c'est à la marche
j'ai pensé en voyant boris johnson à
kiev ce week-end est ce que emmanuel
macron accessoirement toujours président
avec la présence française de l'union
européenne pourrait aller à kiev ça
pourrait être un acte de campagne ou au
contraire une erreur stratégique pour
les noms de l'écho non moi je pensais
serait un acte de campagne qui
certainement contrer parce que ça lui ça
conforte sa stature internationale son
poids de présidente d'europe etc mais
moi je rejoins bien ce que vous erwan
lecoeur c'est à dire que je crois que là
il va falloir trouver des arguments
contre marine le pen on peut pas
simplement agiter la peur de l'extrême
droite il faut et pour l'instant ce soir
en tout cas ce que j'ai entendu je n'ai
pas trouvé qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'arguments puissant et rationnels pour
expliquer qu'elle était la véritable
véritable danger marine le pen sert
qu'on a dit qu'il fallait pas une voix
pour contre marine le pen sont les
candidats de gauche l'ont dit valérie
pécresse l'a dit mais aucun d'entre eux
n'a argumenté n'a dit qu'elle était
véritablement le danger or marine le pen
elle a tellement lisse et que finalement
on ne sait plus l'attraper elle est et
donc il va falloir re et argumentée
c'était une question qui concerne tout
le monde évidemment qui concerne
emmanuel macron au premier chef est
celui qui va jouer son éjection c'est
emmanuel 8 contre est vrai que dans les
derniers jours de campagne avant ce
premier tour on a quand même entendu
emmanuel macron taper sur marine le pen
et notamment sur l'europe c'est aussi
l'avenir de l'europe qui se joue dans
dans cette élection un candidat pro
européen et l'autre plus souverainiste
oui bien sûr mais on le voit c'est
évident et c'est ça fait ça fait
longtemps que c'est évident enfin
d'autres pour en parler encore mieux que
moi mais rapidement l'extrême droite
internationalement s'est recomposée
autour d'un certain nombre de réseaux
sociaux qui sont devenus des réseaux
principalement anti européen anti union
européenne très clairement financées
soutenu alimentée par le kremlin d'un
côté et des officines proche du kremlin
dont l'homme de l'île l'homme lige en
europe est clairement viktor orban réélu
triomphalement en promettant deux choses
a juste le pétrole et le gaz hr et en
roubles ça il l'a promis et il l'aura
mais aussi la paix c'est à dire qu'en
fait viktor orban comme le président
serbe ont dit vous savez si vous votez
pour moi vous aurez la paix poutine
verra pas nous embêter si vous votez
pour les autres je peux rien vous
promettre donc marine le pen pourrait
aussi jouer ce rôle là et quelque part
l'europe n'est plus de n'est plus du
tout comme quand moi je faisais mes
études à bruxelles en sciences
politiques et aux yeux clairement
l'europe dans les années 90 c'était une
sorte de
davantage c'était un endroit qu'on
voulait atteindre à tout prix
aujourd'hui l'europe dans la population
française est synonyme de pas le droit
au camembert au lait cru pas le droit à
ceci des taxes plus importante mais elle
a aussi montré son importance son
utilité oui et non il a aussi montré
elle a aussi montré que les données
personnelles au niveau européen c'était
un peu compliqué elle a aussi montré
qu'il y avait une espèce de big brother
européen qui pouvait nous regardé d'un
drôle d'air sans l'arrêt des vaccins en
commun sur un certain nombre de dettes
mutualisé
de type rationnelle auprès des gens qui
sont le plus au courant qui suivent
l'actualité ça va fonctionner et j'ai
envie de vous dire une bonne partie des
électeurs de mélenchon et de la gauche
qui suivent ces éléments là qu'ils ont
tout ça en tête qui sont pro européen
votre eau emmanuel macron sans coup
férir au deuxième tour mais tous les
autres les électeurs mélenchonistes les
électeurs qui se disent encore vaguement
de gauche et qui n'ont pas trop suivi
tous et qui ne fonctionne plus sur un
mode rationnel moi je suis assez
d'accord et de qualité 10 par martial la
politique c'est pas de la science c'est
pas des mathématiques dans des passions
la colère contre la raison je vous
entends d'une certaine façon c'est ce
que la maison voulait mettre en scène et
c'est ce que c'est ce qui risque
d'entraîner sa chute s'il n'est pas
capable de maîtriser cela allez on va
ouvrir un chapitre dans ce débat
consacré aux partis traditionnels
lr l'est républicain puis le parti
socialiste on commence avec la
déclaration de valérie pécresse un
extrait de sa déclaration
ce soir je suis profondément inquiète
pour l'avenir de notre pays alors que
l'extrême droite n'a jamais été aussi
près de l'emporter
en épargnant au premier tour les
extrêmes et en esquivant le débat
démocratique emmanuel macron a joué avec
le feu et fait prendre un énorme risque
à la france nous pourrions tous en payer
le prix
vous le savez j'ai construit mon
engagement politique contre les extrêmes
de droite comme de gauche je les ai
toujours combattue avec force et
constance ainsi et malgré les profondes
divergences que j'ai martelé tout au
long de la campagne
je voterai en conscience emmanuel macron
pour empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
marine le pen et le chaos qui en
résulterait voilà valérie pécresse qui
finit donc
cette campagne sous la barre des
5% qui je le rappelle permet le
remboursement des frais de campagne
électorale en fait de la totalité des
frais de campagne électorale on retrouve
tout de suite steve jourdain pour un
résumé de cette soirée au qg de valérie
pécresse
oui ambiance très lourde ici à la maison
de la chimie ambiance de fin de règne
ambiance de veillée de très très gros
orage ne sait pas vraiment quelle image
utilisée pour vous décrire ce qui a été
ressenti ici ce soir enfin les militants
les républicains ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les responsables aient
l'air sont partis tout de suite après le
discours de valérie pécresse valérie
pécresse s'est exprimée à aux alentours
de 20h20 elle a appelé à voter au second
tour pour emmanuel macron exactement ce
qu'avait fait françois fillon en 2010
est la différence avec 2017 c'est
évidemment l'ampleur de la défaite cette
défaite historique pour le grand parti
gaulliste -2 5% personne ici ne s'y
attendait ne s'attendait à une telle
raclée racler le mot a été prononcé à
plusieurs reprises par les militants des
militants qui attendent de savoir quelle
sera la suite demain il y aura une
réunion du comité stratégique à 10
heures ensuite ce sera au tour du bureau
politique et enfin réunion du groupe
parlementaire aux alentours de 16 heures
c'est un risque de secouer il va falloir
suivre c'est avec grande attention
catherine tricot n'a l'impression de
vivre la fin des partis traditionnels ce
soir est-ce que c'est finalement
l'achèvement de la stratégie d' emmanuel
macron commencer par siphonnaient la
gauche en 2017 pour arriver à achever la
droite en 2022 abbas et oui ça on peut
dire ça j'en suis bien résumé ce qui est
quand même frappant c'est que malgré
tout il
il arrive à casser tout le monde ça
c'est certain mais finalement au total
il y fait pas un succès formidable il
passe de 24 à 28 alors que la droite
passe de 20 à 5 c'est à dire que
l'électorat de droite a quitté les lr
largement pour aller du côté de
maquereaux mais ça veut dire qu'à une
partie du côté de mac ou qu'il est aussi
reparti peut-être du côté de mélenchon
ou dans l'abstention ou je ne sais mais
ça veut dire que sauf le d'emmanuel
macron il a été élu avec des voix de
gauche en 2017 il est aujourd'hui élu
avec des voix la droite ah ben je pense
que ça c'est tout à fait clair
d'ailleurs sauce il à gouverner avec la
droite il a fait une proposition de
droite pour la suite et il a eu le
soutien enfin des et les poids lourds
alors dans le sud c'est absolument
massif de soutien de la droite à
emmanuel macron mais le silence de
nicolas sarkozy la proposition qu'il a
faite je choisis le premier ministre et
j'ai cinquante députés je veux dire le
fait qu'ils ne soutiennent pas valérie
pécresse c'était un secteur un
dépassement qui peut se poursuivre une
recomposition qui va continuer et une
éventuelle coalition parce que c'est ça
finalement le projet de fait ce qu'il
veut sarkozy pour cela il s'est
éventuellement une coalition avec des
députés l est républicain qui
rejoindrait le convaincront oui je pense
que le téléphone d'edouard philippe doit
vraiment chauffer un certain nombre de
députés et l'air sortant et qui doivent
eux s'interroger dans leur
circonscription pour savoir sous quelle
étiquette il aurait le plus de chances
de l'emporter ensuite est-ce que c'est
vraiment le est ce que c'est vraiment le
chantier politique d'un président pour
un deuxième mandat qui ne sera
constitutionnellement pas candidat à sa
réélection là je pense que on a vu qu
emmanuel macron finalement la vie d'un
parti politique ce n'était pas la
principale principale préoccupation de
dire qu' il va falloir que des leaders
politiques de cette grande famille ce
grand bloc parce que c'est bien sûr
c'est la droite et l'air c'est une
gauche compatibles les appels à voter
mais le macron de l'ancien ministre de
françois hollande marisol touraine
françois rebsamen et puis
deux nouveaux députés heller qui vont
effectivement enfin écouté avec un score
en dessous de 5% pour beaucoup des plus
belles en fuite en avant
une fuite je sais pas de quelle ampleur
mais forcément on va avoir beaucoup de
députés qui vont probablement de façon
timide mais résolue je fis sheila
burckhardt majorité présidentielle mais
est ce que on se prenait se pose et on
est il à sion au parti et essayer de
comprendre ce qui peut se passer demain
lors de ce bureau politique quand on
écoute ce que eric ciotti a dit ce soir
très vite après le l'annnonce du
résultat qu'il n'appelle qu'ils ne
voteraient pas emmanuel macron que
c'était contraire à ses valeurs il n'a
pas dit qu'il appelait à voter marine le
pen mais bon on est là quand même sur
une
fissure que qu'on voit s'élargir devant
nos yeux au fait tu valérie pécresse ait
eu quand même deux adversaires ou sein
d'une famille très large à la fois
emmanuel macron une partie des électeurs
ont quitté valérie pécresse très vite
d'ailleurs après sa victoire à la
primaire et puis une autre partie enfin
quand on regarde le vote françois fillon
en 2017 c'est quand même très éclairant
d'observer que aujourd'hui valérie
pécresse n'était en mesure d'avoir qu'un
tiers de l'électorat de françois villon
de 2017 et 40 % ont voté manuel macro et
à 25% à voter eric zemmour 40% emmanuel
macron donc forcément l'avenir du parti
et l'air c'est au fond ce qui cinq ans
plus tôt étaient les questions nous
avions sur le parti ça veut dire qu'à
droite on peut s'attendre à une scission
peut-être pas dès demain mais dans l'est
dans les semaines qui viennent en fait
les mois qui viennent avec moi ma
théorie c'est qu'en réalité le parti
socialiste ait l air et lé canard sans
tête c'est à dire des zombies des partis
politiques déjà mort le parti socialiste
à peu près vers le 21 avril 2002 c'est à
peu près son saut sa date de mort
clinique mais comme les zombies dans les
films qui sont adorés par les
adolescents et qui deviennent quasiment
une réalité puisqu'on a énormément bien
le phénomène du zombie c'est un
quelqu'un qui est un peu mort mais qui
encore un petit peu vive enfin ça aulas
en est arrivé au pouvoir entre oui ce
n'est pas grâce au parti socialiste
parce qu'au sein du parti socialiste
françois hollande qui était monsieur 3%
il a gagné parce que les autres se sont
en dernier fit côté dans les files de
sofitel pour l'un d'eux tout un tas
d'autres choses pour les autres mais
c'est pas françois hollande n'a pas
c'est pas le parti qui apporte et
françois hollande il n'était plus le
chef du parti justement le parti
socialiste n'a plus de chef depuis à peu
près le 21 avril 2002 réellement et ne
met plus son chef comme candidat n'a
plus de militants ou presque qui
décident de quel est le programme ils le
font par avec des think tanks et le
député qui est le candidat puisque c'est
des primaires qui le font et par
ailleurs ils ont dû vendre solférino ils
sont et à droite alors et de la même
façon à droite depuis la fin de l'ump
quelque part la droite n'a plus
d'existence réelle en tant que le grand
parti de gouvernement on faisait un
colloque sur ce sujet il ya quelques
fans d'un séminaire sur ce sujet avec
mon laboratoire on voit bien la
déliquescence absolu depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale est en fait
depuis les années 80 des grands partis
de gouvernement qui faisait 30 40 % mais
c'est quoi ya pas eu de travail
programmatique tous cas pas eu de
travail programmatique avec travail tout
court je disais sur ce plateau il ya peu
de temps en effet les partis ne
travaille plus non plus de formation de
leurs cadres avant qu'il soit élu ces
gens là ne savent pas ce qu'ils vont
faire n'a plus non plus de militants
dire que en gros le c'est bien joli le
militantisme 2.0 ça fait pas les
militants ça fait pas des gens dans la
vraie vie non plus donc que ce soit à
gauche ou à droite il n'ya plus partie
et elle veut rentrer dans la catégorie
il ya quasiment plus partie des
mouvements il ya le mouvement autour
jean luc mélenchon l'abbé la france est
soumise s'il était président il
s'appellerait comment le président a
soumis un soumis à quoi à la loi n'ont
donc la france a soumis c'était juste un
mouvement comme le front national ait un
mouvement et comme emmanuel macron a
créé un mouvement et pas du tout un
parti donc l'air d'épargnants
composition recomposer la vie politique
sont des mouvements qu'en réalité elle
est déjà recomposée depuis longtemps sur
cette tripolarisation sociologique et
qui est en train de devenir politique et
donc sociologiquement eric zemmour est
en train de d'émerger dans le champ
politique comme l'homme qui fait
l'espèce de jonction entre une droite
ancien et une impopulaire d'extrême
droite lepéniste et il essaie d'être
l'homme qui fait la jonction comme
maigret l'avait théorisé des ailes dès
les années 80 donc lui il est au coeur
de ce pôle là quelque part il est la
droite l'extrême droite pure et dure il
est au coeur de l'identité
emmanuel macron il tient son camp et son
camp en effet c'est son camp libéral
gestionnaire et il tient ce camp-là 1 et
dans ce camp il va avoir edouard
philippe il va avoir des anciens du ps
des anciens élèves qui vont leur allée
le voir parce que à un moment donné
c'est lui qui va donner les investitures
c'est lui qui va dispenser ses bienfaits
la grande victoire de françois bayrou
d'un grand centre
fait que réussir là où mahler avait
échoué en france cran parce que là
tripolarisation elle est bien non pas et
pour des gens luc mélenchon la même
chose est en train de se passer je vous
je fais juste remarquer il n'y a plus un
seul parti à gauche au delà de 5 alors
justement jean luc mélenchon on va
parler d' anne hidalgo tout de suite
vous propose d'abord d'écouter un
extrait de sa déclaration ce soit anne
hidalgo quai sous la barre des 2% des
suffrages exprimés selon nos partenaires
de l'institut ipsos et sopra et steria
on écoute d'abord la candidate
socialiste
je sais combien vous êtes déçu ce soir
et nous tirons bien sûr ensemble tous
les bilans de façon objective
mais vous savez que nous ne baissons
jamais que je ne baisse jamais les bras
je veux parler à toutes celles et ceux
que j'ai rencontrés
partout en france à toutes celles et
ceux pour qui je me bats les premiers de
corvée d'abord qui sont au front pour
que notre pays reste debout les ouvriers
les employés les infirmières les
professeurs les agriculteurs et les
agricultrices et toutes celles et ceux
qui font aussi vivre notre beau pays de
leur créativité de leur générosité et de
leur engagement
je veux vous dire j'en fais le serment
ce soir que je continuerai à mettre
toute mon énergie de femmes politiques
et de citoyenne pour une france
républicaine plus fort belle
une autre réaction celle tout simplement
d'une militante socialiste recueillis
par nos équipes qui étaient donc au qg
de la candidate socialiste je pense que
c'était flora sauvage et marion vigreux
de tous les concitoyens il faut qu'on se
réveille je pense collectivement là on a
fait peut-être de pur sang mêlé et leur
ont fait 5 % aussi on a plus de gnaque
gauche forte mon appui de droite quand
non plus est lorsqu'on n'a pas de pôle
démocratique qui s'affrontent moi je
veux pas qu'ils extraient meur soit les
deux seules références
aujourd'hui pour pour mon peuple c'est
surtout quand on voit ce qui se passe
dans le monde fin je comprends pas va
falloir aller chercher chaque voix à
convaincre les gens de voter déjà
convaincre les gens de voter ce que j'ai
l'impression j'ai pas eu un été l'âge
pays les résultats de l'abstention mais
juste comprendre qu'elle était quand
même encore un peu élevé
voilà donc il faut aller chercher le
plus de voix possible et puis convaincre
qu'il faut
faire le choix de john apaisé jeudi
revoilà pas céder aux extrêmes pas céder
aux peurs irrationnelles et rationnelle
à quatre entre quand on voit cette
militante dépité effectivement d'un
parti traditionnel parti socialiste à
terre ce soir mais là je pense qu'elle
fait une erreur d'analysé quand elle dit
il n'ya plus de face et les extrêmes moi
je crois pas que l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon est un électorat extrémistes
franchement je pense qu'elle finira des
ados que jean luc mélenchon est pas très
bien de la gauche aujourd'hui après je
pense que c'est quand même
l'essentiel des gens qui ont voté pour
jean luc mélenchon l'ont fait parce
qu'il est apparu comme étant celui qui
pouvait représenter la gauche et douzy
tout à l'heure c'était un pôle social
écologique mais en fait c'est ce pôle
social écologique et la forme
contemporaine la forme du 21e siècle de
la gauche la gauche elle a été au xxème
siècle essentiellement sur la question
sociale est là elle devient social et
écologique et jean luc mélenchon a su
donner une forme un discours une
représentation à ça alors là la forme
politique sauf qu'elle n'est pas mature
c'est à dire qu'on est sur une forme de
mouvement c'est à dire quelque chose qui
qui est un petit peu évanescent qui est
présent lors des élections puis qui
disparaît puis qui remonte ekir
disparaît et donc ça ne permet pas
peut-être d'avoir d'abord une continuité
un ancrage et une discussion collective
mais en dehors de ça on ne peut pas dire
que jean luc mélenchon est un extrême
lille et la forme moderne de la gauche
et je sens tout cet accord n'a pas bien
où il est non seulement je suis d'accord
mais en plus même dans les analyses je
dirais de sciences politiques à aucun
moment personne ne pense que jean luc
mélenchon représente l'extrême gauche ça
n'existe pas il représente une gauche
comme die linke en allemagne comme
d'autres en grèce ou dans d'autres pays
en espagne la rencontre ce qui est un
peu mort c'est le centre gauche et le
centre droit c'est l'alternance du
centre qui se passe la balle avec un
petit peu plus de gauche est un petit
peu plus de droite selon entre laurent
fabius et dominique strauss kahn et
laurent fabius pour le dire rapidement
et l'autre côté françois bayrou et
quelques autres de l'autre côté d'un
clivage qui n'existait plus depuis très
longtemps ça c'est une première chose je
voulais juste ajouter un petit enis et
éléments pour la première fois il ya eu
un vote des moins de 18 ans on a peu
parlé mais les moins de 18 ans ont
voté à plus de 2000 exemplaires il
ya un groupe de jeunes
un groupe de jeunes c'est une
organisation une association qui a mené
auprès de 6000 jeunes de moins de 18 ans
donc de 10 à peu près 10 à 18 ans et on
a les résultats et les résultats sont
assez éloquents dire que emmanuel macron
arrive en tête très clairement autour de
30% jean luc mélenchon arrive derrière
environ 20% yannick jadot arrive
derrière 7 8 % et marine le pen et tous
les autres arrivent ensuite c'est
intéressant parce que cette génération
qu'on appelle la génération climat la
génération de la tat une merde elle a
ses priorités et elle va voter bientôt
je dis cela aussi parce que non
seulement au deuxième tour ils vont
encore votée vous pouvez regarder sur
internet ses enfants 2022 est donc cette
expérience est assez intéressante parce
qu'elle repose une question les 18 30
ans ont quasiment pas voté ou très peu
voté à cette élection comme aux
élections municipales régionales etc on
a une génération qui n'a pas voté c'est
à dire qu'elle n'est pas politisé pas
s'exprime différemment son engagement
pour exactement il ya des engagements
qui ne m'aiment pas forcément la
génération qui m'a par exemple s'engage
énormément dans les rues hier mais va
pas forcément voté par exemple pour
yannick jadot ou pour d'autres même pour
me elle a peut-être voter pour des longs
champs ce que ça veut dire aussi c'est
que cette génération là les 18 25 18 30
ne vaudra peut-être jamais vous vous
rendez compte que ça vous dire c'est à
dire que en fait ce qu'on appelle une
carrière des lecteurs ça commence à 18
ans et ça se finit vers 75 ans est
d'ailleurs parfois on voit toujours la
même chose à 75 ans vous êtes à l'armée
c'était là ce soir
emmanuel macron un prix des plus de 70
ans marine le pen a pris les 30 50 et
jean luc mélenchon a pris le 18e vert ça
vous fait réagir parce que je pense que
c'est un peu caricatural comme s'il n'y
avait que les plus de 70 ans qui avait
voté macro comme s'il n'y avait que les
30-50 ans qu'avait votée sur des humains
enfin c'est juste c'est peut-être des
tendances mais je dire en sortant un bon
enfin du jeu peut-être que c'est déjà
ressenti des sources mais ça me semble
un peu caricatural de cette façon de
près de présenter les choses et c'est
pas parce qu'on n'a pas voté entre 18 25
ans qu'on votera jamais si le ca
sociologiquement je suis désolé une
carrière de lecteurs du genre à 18 ans
et tous les
bougnats les marais patron tout fait et
tout ce qui en découle sociologiquement
alors on va dire que peut-être
politiquement vous pourrez être amené à
voter ou peut-être pour des raisons
familiales ou amoureuse quand on va vous
pousser à voter un sociologiquement vos
avez sûrement raison mais la sociologie
n'étant pas tout ni de rêve n'étant pas
non plus une science aussi exact pas
plus que sur ce politique la
géopolitique donc on va rester prudent
là dessus les les contextes électoraux
sont aussi importants les personnalités
pourquoi ai-je à doha n'a pas percé
c'est pas parce que les jeunes n'ont pas
de sensibilité voire des moins jeunes
qui peuvent être tout aussi préoccupé à
l'écologie c'est parce qu'il n'avait pas
il il ne donnait pas l'idée de pouvoir
être le président sur tous les problèmes
qu'il allait avoir à régler il faisait
pas président si vous voulez vous avez
rappelé une source très juste c'était
macro qui au fond avait l'habitude
presse du président peut-être parce
qu'il était déjà mais en 2017 il avait
réussi malgré son jeune âge a certes
donné à penser qu'ils pouvaient l'être
président et jadot ça a été son point
faible il n'a pas suscité l'adhésion au
delà de ce qui était un militantisme
écologique même si je crois à l'opinion
publique est aujourd'hui prêt à prendre
conscience de la gravité de la de la
situation et qu'il faut vraiment se se
bouger et correctement se bouger c'est
pour ça que je pense que ma france c'est
un si j'étais cuit mais je ne suis pas
je très sincèrement je
focaliserait sur
l'écologie pour mobiliser ce que marine
le pen ne fera pas martial foucault le
chiffre de l'oci de l' abstention
prévisible au second tour est ce que
c'est l'un de ceux qu'on va devoir
regarder le plus près pour imaginer ce
que sera ce que sera le résultat du
scrutin
toujours il faut toujours commencer par
les tensions et pourquoi mais pourquoi
parce que il ya déjà des phénomènes
évidemment de démobilisation comme on
dit la participation différentiel à la
fois sur des questions de sociologie des
électorats la géographie elle est
importante je je regardais tout à
l'heure les résultats à la commune par
commune macron 28% on voit qu'il ya un
renforcement sur tout l'ouest de la
france là où il avait déjà réussi à des
scores très élevés donc cette
progression c'est un renforcement dans
l'ouest et il est parvenu pour moi c'est
une vraie surprise à s'installer dans le
grand quart nord-est de la france sur le
territoire de la droite avait sur et
avec classique et c'est intéressant
parce que pour le second tour est-ce
qu'on va retrouver des gir des niveaux
de participation géographique qui vont
permettre finalement à emmanuel macron
de franchir cette difficulté face à
marine le pen parce qu'on pourrait
penser que en alsace il y aurait une
proximité plus grande pour pour leur
assemblée nationale je crois que c'est
pas c'est pas aussi simple que j'avais
un petit sursaut de participation au
deuxième tour de 2017 est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre au même sursaut pour le 24
avril moi je pense que la campagne veut
enfin il faut répéter un point c'est que
même pour une campagne présidentielle
si le sait qu'un jour il n'y a pas un un
enjeu je dis pas 10 en jeu un seul enjeu
fort qui va permet de structurer les
positions terre une thématique forte oui
il faut pas s'attendre
un sursaut considérable de voilà de
participation est donc cet enjeu
effectivement il ya l'enjeu écologique
mais il ya aussi quelque chose qui me
semble très important et vite parce que
je crois que c'est pas on est des enjeux
très sectoriel de politiques publiques
est un sujet en lait qui est très
important c'est c'est la question du
politique le rapport au politique qu'est
ce qui fait communauté politique est là
pour le moment c'est vrai que mme naima
qu'on peut être pris au piège d'être un
président très technique car il va
adresser un grand un procès de militants
sa marine le pen nous dire à ce régime
là
l'écologie ce sera la retraite à 65 ans
ouais enfin l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est ça qui va cristalliser
c'est ça qui va arriver le changement et
je pense que les autres candidats par
exemple anne hidalgo ou yannick jadot
non pas imprimer la campagne avec une
proposition ils ont ils sont peut-être
écologisme en fond qu'est ce qu'on
retient pas grand chose d'eux tandis que
marine le pen et emmanuel macron l'un
comme l'autre ont marqué la campagne et
qui leur position sur la route catherine
et merci merci appelé hier participer à
ce débat alors dans l'ordre je vous
propose de donner de revoir les
résultats peut-être en tout cas des
estimations ipsos sopra star hier du
premier tour si vous les avez les amis
sinon voila merci trop fort merci
philippe 27,6 pour emmanuel macron 23
pour marine le pen
troisième position jean luc mélenchon
avec 22,2 pour cent des voix et reg
zemmour 7,2 pour cent valérie pécresse
4,8 pour cent lla nick shadow sous la
barre des 5 4,7 jean lassalle 3,1 fabien
roussel 2,3
nicolas dupont aignan 2,1 pour cent à
hidalgo 1,7 pour cent philippe poutou 0
7% et nathalie arthaud
0,6 pour cent et les projections pour le
second tour c'est un 54 46 selon ipsos
sopra steria pour emmanuel macron
évidemment on est très prudent ça va
évoluer d'autres instituts de sondage
donnent des écarts plus faibles
devraient remercier toutes les équipes
lcp et public sénat albert ripamonti
perrine tarneaud des films gouédard il
avait le pain c'est philippe de sonic
était à la réalisation ce soir j'en suis
sûr
merci parce que sans vous on n'est rien
dans une soirée merci évidemment à tous
nos reporters qui étaient sur le terrain
et dans les principes au qg ce soir pour
vous faire vivre cette élection
présidentielle ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et on vous
donne bien évidemment rendez vous pour
le second tour c'est pas thomas oui on
se lancera le 24 avril les équipes de
programmation faut pas les oublier voilà
réussi trouver si sa mère les rédactions
lcp public sénat bien sûr merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi et on va se
quitter avec les très grandes
déclarations des principaux candidats
bonne soirée